okay good morning everyone uh so can i
welcome everyone to mid-southwest
development control committee a
um
just need to remind us some of the
domestic domestic arrangements before we
make a start
can i please ask you to ensure that you
maintain social distancing from other
persons while in the chamber in the
communal areas please do ensure you wear
a face mask at all times unless you're
sitting down or of course if you're
exempt from doing so
and that can i remind you to please use
hand sanitizers and the wipes provided
can you please ensure microphones are
turned off when you're not actually
speaking
and please can ask not
people not to interrupt each other or
other speakers or to hold separate
conversations when others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave to ask
everyone just to check their mobile
phones or at least on silent or switched
off and can i also ask those that have
laptops open to make sure uh the
volume's right down so we don't get
pings coming in as your emails gather
thank you
we will be using the e-voting system
today for this meeting on the modern
dot gov app so could ask members just to
make sure you are logged on
i'm ready to use the app if if you can i
know some people can't do that today
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting is being broadcast live on the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewings the whole of the meeting will
be recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting today you'll be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you're also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members republican press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and press are
not lawfully
if you hear the alarm today can i please
ask you to leave the building
immediately via the fire exit and make
our way to the assembly point at ipswich
town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exit at each end of the floor
please do not enter the atrium which is
the ground floor area and walkways
if you are in the atrium when the alarm
sounds please also follow the signs to
the nearest fire exit
please do use the stairs and not the
lifts and do not re-enter the building
until we're told it is safe to do so
well that
covers that off um so just quick
introductions there may be some members
of the public here who haven't been to a
planning meeting before
so my name is matthew hicks
i will be chairing this meeting i'm one
of the councillors and with my
colleagues here on my immediate left
we're the councillors that'll make a
decision on the applications before us
today at mid-south district council you
may not vote on an application in your
own ward but you may speak
we also have philip isabel the chief
planning officer we have ian de perez
our legal adviser
and we have mandy and claire our
governance officers and during the
morning you'll see case officers coming
in to present applications uh one at a
time so i'm going to move on to the
agenda but just before we do that we
have had two uh the agenda items that
won't be heard before committee today
and these are uh
the item first of all number c in our
papers dc2105063
at the land south of forest road one
house and the dc 2004 296 stoneham
barnes both of those applications have
been uh withdrawn from the meeting today
okay
so first item on the agenda apologies
for absence and substitutions do we have
any please
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor humphreys and councillor
carsten is substituting
thanks very much okay
do we need to receive any decorations to
pecuniary or non-pecuniary interest by
members councillor casten
thank you very much mr chairman um i
have a non-pecuniary
um
but slightly um
vague interest
um just for transparency in um
in eight f
um the great brice at business park i've
um
i've got um a cousin who in a separate
job
does um
visual and light impact appraisals
and she's my a director of the company
i'm in which should do not do the same
business that's a completely separate
company that she's done that for but
purely for transparency
yes sir am i am i logged on here yes
councillor cast chairman councillor
casten has taken my advice and i think i
have understood correctly your
um
your cousin who's also a partner in your
your farm business
has
you've not benefited from the
professional fee that she has charged
the the applicants in this matter and
you said it was a separate business
um
yeah no in no way no way so that's fine
i think i force it ought to be declared
but it's not a problem
okay thank you for that always i think
it's always best if i'm sure just to
have that declaration
okay so we'll move on to decorations of
lobbying
any received yeah
council manson
um i i've been lobbied um by the county
councillor for ae
haven't we all i assume we've sent it to
everybody uh i saw an email yes
okay thank you
anyone else anything else nope okay
thank you very much we'll move on
um any decorations of personal site
visits by members
none received okay none thank you
so we've got confirmation of the minutes
of of two meetings before us
um so the first ones we will do will be
the let's do them in uh date orders the
first one would be wednesday the 8th of
december do you remember we had to look
at these last time and we just had to
make a quick change has everyone seen
the revised version
um
so
can i have a proposal to accept the
minutes yes councillor eben and seconded
by councillor passmore
the governance officer will now conduct
an electronic vote on those
thank you chair members if you
select the cross in the top right hand
corner of your app and scroll down this
vote is now in progress
council field
thank you
thank you members chair that's seven
votes for one abstention
okay thank you very much and then we
move on to the minutes of the meeting
held on the 12th of january uh again
they've been circulated to us uh
if you are happy if there's
no you want to come in cancer event
um thank you chair page um 21
um so the first page of those minutes it
doesn't give any details of who was in
attendance
um i know that councilor geek was spoke
at the meeting on the um
application award
and i assume there were case officers
attending as well so um
that's all been missed off page 21.
thank you chair
i couldn't tell you who
thank you councillor evan i think we've
had a technical hitch on those ones so
i'll reissue those
thank you well spotted okay so we'll
move on um
two do we need to receive any
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
no the minutes are coming back
yeah
so do we need to receive any
notifications or petitions in calls for
the council's petition scheme let me see
thank you okay so we'll move straight on
to the schedule the planning
applications we're going to stay in the
same order as they are in the paper so
the first application is
dc2100609 land to the south of i
airfield and north of carstrom way i so
i'm going to hand over to the case
officer daniel cameron to introduce the
item to the committee
thank you um
thank you chair um
[Music]
yes we've got um a reserved matters
application
for phase one of development online to
the south of high airfield and north of
castleton way in i
the reserve matters deal with matters of
appearance landscaping layout and scale
for 138 dwellings including affordable
housing car parking open space provision
and associated infrastructure
um if we look at the aerial map we have
the outline of the entirety of the
site approved by the outline application
matters of access were also agreed at
outlined stage and i'll keep pointing
this out for members
but it's quite an important
consideration
the main access for the development is
to come from castleton way
and it's come through the site
there is then to be a parcel of land
developed
here at the top for 15 dwellings and a
care home
and that is the only parcel of land
within the entirety of the site that is
allowed to make access onto lantern
grove and i'll go through
as we come through the master plan and
the
phase one works show how we've
kept that in place
if we come slightly further out we can
see
our airfield immediately to the
northwest of the site we then have the
rest of i
to the south and to the east we have
yaxley over in the west and then we have
the edge of
rome up at the
top if we move on to the constraints map
you can see we've got some potentially
contaminated land we've
already addressed matters of land
contamination within the outlying
application
and that is acceptable and we have
detailed conditions on the outline to
address those matters as well the other
thing to note is we've obviously got a
number of listed properties
on this road into i and obviously we've
got the higher concentration within i
itself and within the content
conservation area of our itself as well
we've also got a number of pulley rights
of way and it's a shame that so many of
them are under the
this grey
here
um but we have a number that crisscross
the site one that passes through and as
we move on i'll go over a connectivity
plan for you members that just details
that and show us how connectivity within
the site will join up with the public
rights of way as well
we've also got the um this blue area
that is the high pressure gas
buffer zone
we have no housing
within the the scheme within that buffer
zone
and we also have a number of
biodiversity elements that again have
been picked up with ecology consultants
at outline stage so we already have
conditions in place on the outline to
address those
to just take a quick step back members
this is the master plan that was
approved as part of the outline
again you can see this green buffer
that separates this topmost parcel of
development
um from the rest
a walking route is to be provided such
that pedestrians could make access to
langton grove but there's no car route
through there to be brought forward such
the only dwellings that can make their
access here will be the ones that we'll
talk about in the next item
um all the other
development that forms part of the site
parcels 13a 13b 13c and 14 all make
their connection in
on castleton way
this application deals with parcels 13a
parcel 13b and part of parcel 13c
so if we come back the red line outline
indicates the um
the site area that we'll be looking at
reserve matters for today members we've
got a little spur coming up here this is
part of the spine road that come runs
through the site and we'll come on to
that in more detail but also we've got
this spur off this is to provide a
walking route to victoria hill as part
of these phase one works
and to provide greater connectivity into
i and through the site as well
just turn now to the site layout we've
got 138 dwellings being provided within
this parcel
um
of the 280 approved outline
there are 15 to be considered within the
next item before committee
leaving 127 that would form part of a
phase two works that would come forward
at the later dates
um obviously as part of the outline as
well members you'll see from the report
in front of you that we've got
additional um we've already got section
106 agreed on the site and parts of that
are outlined in section 10.1 of the
report and at the very end of the report
after the recommendation
we've also outlined the conditions
briefly for you as they form part of the
outline
so we're not in a position where we
might be
requiring conditions to be added on
again
um
that's not the one for the right thought
so you can see we have this access this
is to be provided by
a roundabout off castleton way um it's
my understanding that we could at the
moment we have discharge of conditions
applications
in and we have discussions on going with
the highway authority over the provision
of this roundabout from there we then
have a spine road that travels through
the sites
and then we'd have additional arterial
routes connected off and we'd have
parking provided off those arterial
routes
we have a number of large areas of open
space within the site
and we also have some detailed
landscaping plans as well
showing the extent of tree planting
within the site
the only exception to this i would point
out for members is this area here this
is an area of archaeological potential
and is therefore kept slightly freer of
planting where it may then have
potential for root growth in coming
years to
come forward and
interfere
so i mentioned previously we've got this
connectivity plan so the public rights
of way are shown in red
we have them running north south
and we have this one running through the
site and adjacent to the
allotments
adjacent site as well
the main route through the site is shown
in yellow and it doesn't show very
clearly so i'm just outlining it with
the red dot for you members
but we'll have pedestrian and cycleways
provided along the
main route through we've got an
additional walkway through public open
space to be created
around this curve we also have
additional walkways through public open
space
in the south of the site and through the
north of the site and we have the
additional pedestrian connection through
onto victoria hill
in terms of the design of the site this
has been brought forward um through a
number of character areas
um and that's detailed for you in
section 5.2 of your report numbers um in
terms of character areas we have
character area one which is this
gateway feature served from the
roundabout will be the first
view of our you see as you approach from
the a140 down castleton way
and it's outlined in this sort of
beijing color for your members
we have a green edge
so we have a looser urban grain of
development
closer to the countryside
and this is outlined with these
greens
we have
the hayward gateway which constitutes
this teal section
of the crescent around this southern
piece of open space and then also
framing
the open space to the north
and then within these
orangey brick coloured
sections we have a tighter denser grain
of development that forms the
neighborhood housing as we sort of come
closer to
those aspects of the development numbers
i just want to run through
some of the house types
because what we have is
within those character areas
um
certain aspects of
the architecture that you would normally
see within
the town of i have been brought forward
and and demonstrated such that you get
an idea of
the place through
through the house types and we have a
number of different
options so
these are the same house types and the
different treatments that will be
affected to them within the different
character areas so this would form part
of
um
semi-detached housing within character
area one we then have a very different
approach to the same house type use of
render use of
door cases use of slate to roofs we have
chimneys
on certain buildings to create interest
at roofline level
and you'll be able to see that as we
move through the presentation when we
come to look at the uh
the street scenes provided for you as
well members
we'd then move into character area two
the green edge we've got a greater use
of brick we've got use of brick
detailing in string quarters and dental
courses
we've still got slate to roofs
predominantly red bricks some use of
render
we have a move to the neighborhood
housing areas so we have this tighter
grain we don't have as many
um
architectural features we don't have
those sort of flared
brick arches over windows we have
uniform soldier courses but when i come
to show you the photos surrounding the
site as well members you'll see that
actually these areas interface with
existing development with an eye fairly
closely so actually there is a need to
make sure that we are creating a totally
different character type that the two
can sort of be seen together
if we come on now to a more traditional
four bedroom unit again
character area one we have use of render
we have use of bay windows to create
dual frontage
we have some use of clay pan tiles and
brick plinth and we have stone coins on
the edge of buildings
again moving to
character area 2 we again see the brick
detailing slate roofs
we again see some interest in dual
frontage and the use of bays
again character area three this sort of
area that flanks the the two main pieces
of open space within the site
and then character area four sort of
more traditional
appearing unit use of cream render
off-white render
and you'll see from the street scenes
this top street scene just details
part of this gateway and it details this
part part of the gateway that sort of
as you would come from the roundabout
and curves around and we have
um some 3d drawings as well that will
better illustrate the curves for your
members but we have this sort of
um interesting um
roof line varied roof heights number of
chimneys we have
the buildings articulated well around
the curve we have a number of sort of
courtyard access areas to come through
we then sort of move into an exemplar of
this
green edge
around
the other side we have the use of
small dormers at roof height
occasionally we have the string courses
we have this more regular pattern of
development
we have some units turning corners to
better frame
access points and onto open spaces as
well
again we come through we have
examples across this crescent the
hayward green
fronting onto this
southerly part of public open space we
have a higher degree of single-story
units again we have
brick we have some use of height to
denote
key landmarks and key visuals within the
site
we have units articulated to turn
corners so we can get double
visibility on onto those
parts here
and then we also have a part of this
sort of more neighborhood
scale of development again we have this
use of brick we have this use of render
we have slate we have pan tiles within
it and if i move on to the 3d scenes
this is part of the gateway so you can
get a better idea of how that
articulates around the curve
so we have these
bespoke house types
created that actually will
transition round
we have use of a number of different
colours of render as well so it's quite
emblematic of the more sort of
historical sections of eye
we have the units fronting onto um
this green edge we have these larger
looser um
larger gardened areas
we have the the brick detailing we have
occasional chimney use we have
occasional use of slightly taller
buildings to create interest
and then coming around we have the very
edge of the
hayward green we have the bungalows we
have the the frontage on
and we have you know occasional
two-story development there as well
in terms of affordable housing the
strategic housing team have been
consulted and are happy with what's been
brought forward
we have a mix of
affordable rent shared ownership and
discount market rate units and we have
28 affordable houses being provided
within the scheme entirely and that is
consistent with what is agreed within
the section 106 agreement
we also have materials planned showing
sort of the mix within the site and how
the different areas are to be
characterized by their materials choices
and i think the other thing to to bring
on to is the um
open space detailing um
in consultation with the public realm
team they are content with what's being
brought forward and they're they're
pleased to see so much open space being
delivered within the site um they know
eye is sort of slightly deficient in
terms of the amount of open space it can
offer its residents so they're pleased
that we have quite a lot and they're
pleased that we have quite a lot of
connectivity through the site into eye
meaning that the open space doesn't just
be used by
the residents of the site it's open to
the resident survive more widely
you'll see we've got a densely tree
lined
main spine road running through the site
we have additional planting up on this
edge as well
and around the entrance
if we move through we see that
tree-lined avenue continue round through
the spine road
and that continues to run down
we then have
walkways connecting the site north to
south
coming up into this area of open space
we have some sort of desire lines
running through
and if we come across as well you can
see we've actually got some sort of
linear features here to connect into
the allotment site we've got this large
crescent shaped area
here at the south we've also got a small
pocket park
within the site and then that spine road
continues up
through and we'll get additional
landscaping details for the phase two
application at the time that that comes
forward
we have a number of ev charging points
throughout the site and we also have
cycle parking provided for the dwellings
where we have
courtyard parking we have ducting being
provided there
so that when
when later ev might want to be installed
within the different units that can be
achieved
we also have
additional
sustainability measures being brought
forward and you'll note from late papers
that we have comments from the council
sustainability officer
responding to the submission
by
and pegasus so we have some photovoltaic
panels being installed on southern
facing roofs within the site and we're
hoping to have
additional options within the sales
package within the site for additional
photovoltaic panels to be
available within the site
we have insulation on the dwellings
exceeding the requirements of building
regulations and we have
calculated emission rates for the
development should
also exceed the requirements of building
regulations in that regard as well
we do have gas condensing boilers being
proposed for use at the beginning of the
development obviously as building makes
change and the requirement
becomes
the norm for air source heat pumps we
have taken that into account and there
is um design consideration being made to
allow those air or seat pumps to come in
to buildings without significant change
um but obviously we are waiting for
building works to catch up
with that
um
i'll also just quickly note as well in
terms of
comments
um
in terms of public comments to the
scheme
we have comments being raised about the
wind turbines on our airfield
throughout the design process
shadow flickering has been
addressed so we shouldn't have any
issues although we do have conditions on
the turbines on our airfield to require
baffles to be provided
and previous enforcement action has seen
those provided and altered and changed
so i see no reason why we couldn't do
the same again
the other comment that was made um
with regards to responsibility for
maintenance of buffer zones and amenity
areas with the site that's already dealt
with within the the section 106 that
we've already agreed on the outline
application
quickly run through a few
views of the area this is
castleton way
as you move into i we have
existing
semi-detached units
on the north side
we have obviously the hospital and the
school
on the southern side and this is looking
the other way so we have the additional
red brick
concrete pan tile development on the
north side this is heading up
towards the a140
this is further on and you see the field
on the right hand side and this forms
part of the development we can just see
the airfield
turbines off in the distance
and then as we view
through up towards the countryside
you know we can see the topography of
the site is fairly flat it's fairly
undulating
we have these sort of desire lines
created by pedestrians making
walking routes across here and
connecting up with the public rights of
way
and we obviously then looking back from
the site towards development along
castleton way so we have the
the rear part of this first estate that
currently forms the edge of eye
and then if we look towards the
countryside we can see some trees
off in the distance and again towards
the airfield we're flat we're generally
undulating we're not
anything else i'll stop there because
we're about to enter the wonderful world
of house types and unless members have
any specific comments about house types
i might leave those for debate
but with regards to the application the
recommendation before members is that we
approve
the reserve matters
um
we've brought forward a scheme that is
in accordance with
the adopted development plan and in
accordance with the i neighborhood plan
we have
a section 106 scheme already agreed we
have a number of conditions already
agreed that we're
complying with and we have a
development layout that takes this
opportunity to create a new access way a
new entry point a new visual
um
frame with which
to enter
the town
um
and yes i'll leave it there for
questions chair and i'll
answer any that may come forward i've
i've got a whole bunch but who wants to
go first yeah council passed me
um thank you very much um matthew just
two or three fairly quick questions
there's quite a lot of correspondence in
the papers
regarding the housing mix not not the
type of housing i don't have a
difficulty
have it has this some proposal has it
satisfied the issues particularly for
smaller homes the proportion in there
has been addressed as a comment i think
is on page well between page 50 and 54
the various comments the distribution of
the units in there in order to help
particularly first-time buyers has that
been satisfied
so that's one question
i don't know if you want to answer that
first but there's two other
points
the other one i know i bring this up
quite quite regularly about
drainage and water sources and the
porosity or lack of it on driveways
because it is really important when it
comes to flooding
is it possible to condition that if
people agree when we come to the debate
to make sure that the driveways of
course as opposed to being hard surfaced
and then the last one i want to make
mention on the landscaping we've all
seen and i do know the site pretty well
um it is very exposed i just wanted
confirmation there's a lot of
landscaping going on there which is good
does it
are our people satisfied that it's it's
perfectly adequate and i would also like
to know how we and who is going to be
responsible going forward for six seven
years that the landscaping is done
properly and the trees do grow and of
course the trees are native species
sourced locally can we do that
thank you
okay so turning to to mix first
um yeah we have our policy um three
within the neighborhood plan
um
and this is outlined within the the town
council's responses and we've got
representatives of the town council here
today so
they could they can correct me if i'm if
i'm mistaken um at present the mix is
predominantly
um two and three bed i think their
policy would prefer to see a great
proportion of one and two bed units
however
um we've had extensive discussions
between um simmons pegasus ourselves and
the town council on
this issue
um and i think there were a couple of
factors a salient is um one persimmon
have sort of seen a change in preference
from their customers in terms of the
number of houses the number of bedrooms
prospective customers are looking at
whereas before they might have seen
someone come in for a two bed unit the
realities of the last 24 months have
meant that actually there's a greater
desire to be able to work at home so
actually
where they would have before seeing
people come for two bed units they're
now looking for three bed units so they
can have that home office space
within the the comments provided by
italian council and specifically within
the further comments that were received
on the 24th of november
i town council are happy with the mix
i think what they would like to do is um
reopen discussions with regards to the
mix when we come to phase two of the
development i think that is the sensible
approach to make because phase two comes
closer to the the core
of i it will be a tighter grain urban
grain development and actually that sort
of area suits a smaller one and two bed
units
simply because if you were to try and
provide them you know within your
countryside edge
actually
you'd lose a lot of the a lot of the
appearance those those sort of edge of
town
dwellings tended to be
larger served with larger gardens you'd
probably run into an issue
trying to provide those there
the next issue with regards to drainage
and
um
particularly with driveways um we can
get confirmation from persimmon and
pegasus on that and about the materials
and we could ask for
detail of that to come in as part of the
discharge of conditions in general for
drainage across the site our floods and
water team are happy
and obviously with regards to
highways there's generally an
expectation that
um any driveway that's provided within
the development won't then
drain water directly into the highway so
actually you then avoid the issue of
standing water on the highway or ice
forming on the highway in cold weather
with regards to the landscaping
um
just going through i think
we are content with regards to
landscaping we
had some strategic landscaping at
outline we're in accordance with what we
have we're looking at native species
and we have conditions for the
implementation of the landscaping being
being brought forward and then obviously
maintenance of that
while it's being built out will fall on
persimmon and then
as we come through the section 106 for
adoption we've got a cascade system to
determine who will then take forward the
maintenance
that is and i've just been looking
through that's part of an open space
scheme that sits within the section 106
that's already in place and that
includes things like maintenance of the
suds basin and other features so there's
there's a whole scheme to be settled
there but effectively it could be
management company it's more likely to
be something that we discuss about
adoption and the reality then is that
maintenance package is is an ongoing
conversation under the section 106
councilman
uh thank you chair um just to i i too
was going to ask about the housing mix
but but as i follow on from council pass
more's uh question
about the housing mix um i understand
that the um applicant thinks that
three-bedroomed houses are
more um needed or more wanted because
people are working from home uh can we
be assured that these
three-bedroomed homes all meet the
whatever it is space standards and they
haven't just crammed the third one in um
for no good reason um and i believe can
you also clarify i think i read
somewhere i'm sure i'm not i'm not okay
with all the page numbers
um that because there was a um deficit
of two-bedroomed homes in this phase um
the next phase you're gonna there was
some um action to when that comes
forward that that can be rectified
um and i'd also like to ask about um i
think it said somewhere that there was
going to be pedestrian cycle and
emergency access
off haygate and victoria hill
can you just show me on the plans where
they are
where they're going to be thank you
yeah so in terms of um the units we meet
ndss standards um
with regards to the the two bed units
out of one part of discussions for for
phase two persimmon and pegasus are
already aware of that and i'm sure
colleagues at italian council will make
sure we're
um
all singing from the same hymn sheet and
i think the the
the way that um policy i3 is written i
think the way that the town council is
choosing to apply with regards to this
development is right because we do have
a subsequent phase two to come
we can make the development as a whole
compliant with
the policy but obviously at
this phase one stage we are dealing with
that edge of edge of settlement and we
do need to
just be a little bit um
alive to that and make sure our design
reflects that but obviously as we move
into this historic core a tighter urban
grain one and two bed units suit that
better
than they do edge of settlement and we
can look to increase those numbers and
then are we able to just go back to the
presentation oh we might slide as well
um
so we have victoria hill
um
down here
so this is going to come forward as part
of this
application so we'll have the emergency
access we'll have the pedestrian cycle
route through
the scheme there'll probably have to be
some sort of discussion when we come to
phase two because some of this is going
to then come forward at that point there
might need to be some sort of safety
considerations about working practices
and things
there and then i think
i would think the other one might be
down here
might be down here but i need to go back
and check my plans more carefully for
that but we could condition an
informative um
those details so that we're aware of how
those emergency accesses are going to
work you know is it a case if there's a
code is it a case if there's
um
how however that would work we can we
can get the detail on that for you we'll
we'll will the applicant i i i'm more
interested in the pedestrian cycle
access than the emergency vehicle access
will the applicant know exactly where
they are
can i ask can i ask the applicant when
um
when he turns up thank you
thank you councilor
um thank you very much chair thank you
daniel for your presentation um
sorry i've got similar
questions um just on the landscaping
could you just um
because this application says to
consider
appearance layout landscaping and scale
so which landscaping has already been
agreed and which hasn't because i'd be
um concerned about the landscaping
particularly on the north given that the
north east side
given that um the site at our airfield
is is growing developing and so on and
for that to be as
prominent as not the site obviously the
landscaping to shield the housing as
much as possible from the side
um secondly on the housing mix um i
understand that the eye neighborhood
plan is the is the most um recent
adopted
planning document we should be working
to and they ask for 53
two-bedroom homes
now yes some people might be working
from her home more but we've also got
locals presumably that want to downsize
that aren't working from home and even
suffolk says 34
and the amended figures we've got are 18
2 bedroom that's a long way off
so
could we have some clarification perhaps
on the policy point because i thought we
should be
um we're supposed to make an adherence
to our neighborhood plan
first
um before um anything moves on on that
front and thirdly a very quick question
is do we know when these are likely to
be
starting to be built
thank you
if i answer the
last one first and say we can probably
defer to persimmon on that one because
i'll have a much better idea of their
time scales
um coming forward in terms of the
landscaping the overall landscaping
within the entirety of the site will be
dealt with and secured through the
section 106 and the conditions on the
outline we have the landscaping before
us for the part of the red line site
that we are considering
but that does include part of that
northern area of landscaping and all
across that
curve at the north of the site we have a
more
woodland
um
feel to the landscaping so we're
predominantly tree we're looking at
heights
we have some shrubs intermixed
as well
but yes we are aware that actually we
have the airfield beyond we have the
turbines beyond
and we are aware that there is a need to
make sure that actually we create a new
um soft boundary for
eye on this
on this part of the development so we
have taken that into account and brought
that forward
in terms of the mix brought forward in
the eye neighborhood plan
policy i3 does
talk about 53 smaller units we do have
some discount market rate units
within the development smaller units
first time buyers we do have two bed
units being provided within the site and
we also have a number of bungalows being
provided within the site as well as part
of this mix
um the way that the policy is worded
within our neighborhood plan
there is some ambiguity about whether
you apply that policy rigidly to
the reserve matters
and each phase as it comes forward so
each phase is in accordance with
the percentages set out within policy i3
or do you apply it to a development site
as a whole
such that actually at the end of the
phase two negotiations we can include
what we've done in phase one and we can
come out with a number that should
hopefully across the entirety of the
site reflect
what the desire of policy i3 is
um
in terms of where we're where we're
looking
because we are dealing with this phase
one and it is this outer edge um more
than this sort of core of the
development there is this um
requirement in terms of
um
the design of the site and layout of the
site to maybe use that
to bring in the larger units
within this phase of development and
then as you move towards the historic
core
of i
bring in more smaller units bring in a
tighter grain of urban development that
would reflect well
the historic core of i
and then provide the bulk of your one
and two bed units within that second
phase of development
so we do have that um
we do have that in mind we are aware
that colleagues from my town council
will want to see that delivered um and
in our discussions with persimmon and
pegasus they are under no illusions that
you know we are looking for an increased
delivery of one and two bed units when
we come forward
phase two however that comes forward and
whenever that comes forward to make sure
that actually across the site we're in
step with
the i neighborhood plan and its
requirements with regards to mix
um thank you very much for that if i can
come back so
the the the two bedrooms detailed in the
papers across the whole
across all top types whether it's
affordable or market housing is 18
so
the suggestion is that for the this
could this committee then for a
condition to say the next phase has does
like 80
mark two bedroom houses i i'm not sure
we could do that but um
i still struggle with that but that can
come up later but and just on the
landscaping then can we are we able to
put in a condition then on this one that
what that would say for example you know
that the landscaping around that north
side is done first or is whatever can
that type of condition be done not
suggesting we have it yet obviously
chairman if i just come in on that um
yeah the mixed question i don't think
because you've got an outline permission
you're dealing with reserve matters for
this phase i think you have to you deal
with this as it is
and accept there's a question to follow
on
uh and obviously as with all policies
and if the facts um warrant a departure
at time you'll have to make that
judgment when that comes up
as regards landscaping um these are the
details of the landscaping to get to
cancer passwords question about porosity
you've got two options really if the
details do not contain sufficient
matters to satisfy at this point
then you can delegate that to
ourselves to
address those matters and get those
details amended so that they do
you have the ability if they are not
included
to impose a condition for those specific
detailed aspects
so that we do have them um so you have a
couple of choices there
and depending on what your what you want
to achieve so for instance council
passwords point about porosity
you could either treat that as being a
materials type condition
or being
a landscape hard landscape condition and
you've got two ways tackling the same
problem
either way the developer will want to
resolve it
um and from our perspective it's
reasonable to to either amend these
details by agreement get that done sign
off and say this detail is what you do
or to
impose a condition so that they then go
away check what stocks available for
particular types of paving materials
because obviously the material supply at
the moment is an interesting question
and then submit something you've got two
options to do there but you can instruct
officers do that as a straightforward
delegated item and if you're
particularly concerned about the phasing
and timing of planting that's something
you can instruct officers to
condition
or seek detail of so that either the
applicant provides it and we have that
timetable quite clearly set down or we
impose a condition which does reinforce
that because
if we sign this off we will expect it to
be done as per the approved details that
we have thank you jim
councilman
thank you chair um
yeah
on the mix i i kind of feel we've we've
moved back from the reassurances that we
had a little bit with mr isabel's most
recent comments
uh you know i've
had you know similar questions to others
um so we are
really not able in determining this
application to to ensure that the
overall mix will be achieved um give or
take the odd couple of percent
which is a bit of a worry really um
but um i suppose it depends how firmly
someone infuses
can i excuse me
i've gone too far in discussion sorry
we're not expressing views at this point
matters of clarity yeah yeah so the the
clarity is that we can't ensure i think
isn't it
so what the what the other one i wanted
to come back to
first really was on the um cancer
passport a question about the porosity
of the driveways and i was particularly
struck by
the environment agency views on page 80
about water resources
and and um what was the phrase about um
recharging them or something like that
uh the groundwater um
so are those two things linked i
don't understand
you know whether
creating more porosity then actually
helps
to deal with the issue that the
environment agency are raising
a bit of help on that one
it's page 81 and 82 that really
discusses it for members
jeremy coming on that um
those
comments
i i would typically say um
there are comments there in relation to
the environment agency's ground water
protection approach their question of
water resources
water is an issue in the eye area um
that's that's clear but i'm
understanding that supply to new homes
is uh is something which is is
safeguarded by the i think it's essex
and suffolk water i think in this area
um in terms of uh the impact of porosity
on on and infiltration in relation to
these things i i imagine it would
probably not be a huge
a fairly imperial contribution to that i
stand to be corrected by an engineer but
my instinct is that
this would not especially
make much difference to that question
and from what i can see in the papers
you have comments about the
investigations that
environment agencies are doing about
reducing public waters abstraction in
future there's no abstraction proposal
here you're dealing with reserve matters
for landscaping for layout for scale
appearance
i think those matters are the kind of
things that you get into when you're
dealing with an outline application so
i'm not sure
to what extent you
see a harm here that needs to be
mitigated because i don't
i think
sorry child i think what i'm looking for
is is can we make can we get a benefit
to the problem
through what counts the past will say
that porosity of driveways etc that you
know is it but you're you know you're
saying it's a tricky question for an
engineer um
so we might have to leave that for now
just to come back on that um council
matson i think it's certainly true that
the more
water that you retain rather than
effectively allow to flow out through
the water courses to the sea
then the greater that has a capacity to
recharge the aquifer over time
i
am skeptical it would make a material
difference um that's unless really at
scale
um even with a development of this size
but i take the point and i think you're
if i'm not putting words in your mouth
what you'd like to see is that by making
driveways porous we ensure that
groundwater is not diverted and run
through watercourses and discharges to
the sea
thank you council
thank you very much mr chairman um can i
have the site layout up please
um
yeah that that one will do but do you
have the one that's um
the the west side that's a bit more
um
yeah perfect
um on that
that bit
that sort of dulled out is the allotment
gardens
that's um this sort of is built around
and on that east
hedge
we've got right
halfway down
we've got a red line i'm going across
there up a bit yeah
we've got that area and there's some on
my map there's a pond in that
area
um and quite a few trees
in this um
in this um plan
it looks like a grass area without a
pond that sort of
hedged off from the rest of the
development with the red line on the
allotment garden side i couldn't find
what
was the um plan for that
and whether that um pond was um
whether that disappeared and also those
trees had disappeared
yeah i think that might be one too
absolutely okay
it might be that they want to leave the
pond as is so it's just a case that the
plan doesn't show it because nothing's
happening to it um
but if it's if it's sort of serving the
allotment gardens at present it might be
worthwhile leaving it to to do so
but shouldn't we
give them ownership of it if it's
if it's going to be hedged off and left
on their side is what i'm saying but
that that maybe is one for the that
might i develop that i would consider
that to be a slightly separate issue so
the red line would denote their land
ownership at this point if their
intention is to provide it to someone
else that is a separate legal matter for
the land registry to to look at it's not
necessarily something that we need to be
detailing within planning
thank you thank you councilman
next chair um can we have slide nine
again please
in the
bottom left there i think it's area 13 a
um i tried to look at the detail online
and i'm afraid
the quality of the image was poor to my
reading of the layout the the houses are
accessed from the road that goes around
that perimeter just above the red dot
i keep going up
left
there that's the in in that area in the
center is that an open green space
and if so um did the crime prevention
officer make any comments about it
no so that is uh courtyard parking
courtyard park for these right for these
dwellings so that's accessed um
when we looked at the 3ds we had the um
the car the carriageways through
covered carriageways through so they
will
in detail so thank you for that second
question um the town council
um raised
concerns about site density and small
garden size
a comment slightly further on saying a
series of meetings resulted in
significant improvements
if
this phase one
has a high density and phase two has a
low density and we start putting
pressure on the developer to put more
um two-bedroom houses in
are we in danger of breaching the
outlying
um
number of houses
so the the number of houses agreed in
the outline is 280 across the entire
site that cannot change without a
further planning application um
the outline is part of the eye
neighborhood neighbour plan as well so
that maximum number of dwellings within
the site
is protected within policy um we have
138 dwellings coming forward here we
have 15 dwellings coming forward within
the next item we're left with 127
to come forward as part of
the final phases but
within within the overall design brief
for the entirety of the site those
phases of development were always seen
as being
closer to
um the rest of i and would be more
um
akin to that sort of uh layout that we
see in the rest of the town anyway so
increasing those
uh numbers of one and two bed units in
that in that phase was always part of
the
overall design brief for the scheme what
about the size of the gardens and
density is it are the gardens
significantly smaller than similar
development
um in terms of garden sizes we've got
good garden sizes coming forward as part
of the
phase one scheme as part of phase two
um you would generally associate a
smaller bedrooms unit with a smaller
garden um although obviously would need
to wait for details of the reserve
matters for the appearance of the layout
etc to then be able to do that but as
part of phase two i envisage having sort
of a number of conversations with
colleagues at italian council and with
persimmon and pegasus to make sure that
the
the scheme that we bring before members
is
acceptable
okay so the garden size is not not small
in this phase one and we can make them
proportionate to the size of the
dwelling and ensure that we have a we
have a mix with it okay thank you thank
you uh casa field
thank you a couple of points on page 58
um
i noticed power 55 talks about gas
condensing boilers
but mentions a green utility connection
to be offered to all purchasers
i was wondering does that just imply
that uh everybody's free to buy a green
tariff or is that actually
implying that the
electrical connection to these houses
will be adequate to support a future
where we have electric cars
electric heating systems
etc i think there's a report later in
our pack that mentions
ensuring that there are 100 amp feeds
into these houses so really
does the electrical feed meet the future
or is it just a bit of green washing
um
the second point really is uh you talk
it's a paragraph above that at the top
of the page you're talking about
exceeding the requirements of building
rates by 10 percent
and the mission by 19 which uh initially
sounds quite reasonable
but i guess those are the building rates
of 2013 are they so some nine years out
of date
i wondered how that stacks up against
the new version of the building regs
which is due out in june or july
and we actually managed to avoid being
modern or are we going along with it
if we look at building meg's question
first we can only
look at what is currently
in place the future building regs the
dwellings will need to make sure that
they abide by
future
building works when they come into force
they're not in force yet we might see a
delay we may see a revision to them we
can't rely on them being
a known force and as well because we
don't have
the detail published
in its final form it would be difficult
to then make the developer adhere to
them when we don't know but as building
rage requirements change across the
scale of the development we will then
obviously see
the requirements for the buildings
change as well so when we come to
increased building regs in the summer
the buildings will need to
accord with building regulations in
their regard and you know the same when
we talk about gas boilers when we see
building regulations phase out the
installation of gas boilers to new build
properties again we'll have to see the
introduction of air source heat pumps or
another heating technology within those
buildings but at present they're
governed by a separate regime
and planning is asked not to interfere
with things that are dealt with by
separate regime
with regards to the electrical feed i
would assume the electrical feed is
sufficient into each dwelling for
its needs at the moment but as well i
think given that we have ducting being
provided across the site given that we
have electric vehicle charging points
and given that within the
time scale of the development we will
see a need to integrate air source heat
pumps into the development i would
assume that the electrical feed would be
adequate but that might be something
that persimmon or pegasus can comment
more further on
or in any case we could then look to use
our informatives if members were so
inclined to ensure that we are clear
that building rigs will be changing
during the lifetime of this
development and that there will be an
increased need for electrical feeds
within
the buildings and the dwellings that to
be brought forward as part of this
application
can i just follow up on on a couple of
those points then so um so does every
house have electric charges
every property so we have
ev for properties that have
garages within the site because that's
simple too can you speak that's simple
that's simple to
implement we have ducting provided while
we have um
uh courtyard parking so that as of when
so why isn't it why isn't it evie
charging at every at every parking place
for every resident
that might be a better question to
direct towards
pegasus and who'll determine when they
stop
supplying gas boilers and move to
alternative energy who makes that call
that's in-house within building
regulations if you want your
building control sign-off completion
certificate
if you're after the point in time at
which that you can legally install the
gas boiler into a dwelling
that's the point in time that you need
to have installed an assault heat pump
or a different
heating solution
on building rigs we have had other
applicants come here where they've said
they've been meeting future building
regs and that's been sort of
sold to us as a reason to support it
so you're saying this applicant is only
basing on the 2013 building wrecks
building regulations are set out
at the moment current building
regulations so it will depend when the
relevant part of the the document was
updated um i don't have that in front of
me so i'll accept that it might be 2013
but we are exceeding building
regulations so at present you could
build to a lower standard
and
within planning because it's governed by
a separate regime
we might not have the powers to impose a
more stringent
so if they start work in a year's time
and the new building regs have come in
they will have to meet those buildings
at least meet minimum building standards
at that point in time yes okay and can i
just final point sir is about car
parking so what are we being asked to
decide today around car parking can you
just give me some clarity on that
so we have the parking set out within
the layout we have the total numbers
um
we have
parking that says adopted parking
standards being provided
we have no instances of triple parking
within the site
we have
garages being provided for most
dwellings but not all and where we don't
provide it we have enough parking within
the visitor parking and within the
courtyard parking areas to be able to
deal with that and then we have
ducting being provided to those areas
to ensure that as and when residents
come forward with an electric car
it's not a case if they need to retrofit
the entire site that the infrastructure
is there and it's just a case of running
the cables through the ducting to the
charging point how whichever charging
method they want to then use they could
presumably implement
thanks i just got one final question um
in the site so you've we've got avenues
of landscaping i can see that going
through the site with the trees
what you might call the avenue in and or
and around and through the site
but there's no in mark that i can see
landscaping amongst the housing so is
there any anything on that you could
just share with us
so we do have soft landscaping coming in
between
units so units that face out onto open
space have a more open field units that
are away from open space have a more um
a more enclosed feel just to create
those areas of privacy within their own
open space
okay so there is so there is further
landscaping
within the site as on top of the sort of
avenues that we can see within the heavy
plant well probably within rear gardens
it will probably be left fairly
standard fairly blank and ready for the
residents to put their own
choices in place and then within the
frontages within those areas that you
know will likely be seen by the public
passing through the site we have a more
detailed soft landscaping thanks
to madison yeah thank you the um thank
you most of my questions for for the
agent of the town council actually but
um just just
briefly on the um building regs point
that the late papers has got um the the
environmental management officers
comment on the the outline
uh condition discharging which talks
about just gently reminding them that
it's going to go up to 31
uh reduction soon but my the other one
other point i wanted to understand from
from uh daniel was the
that that let me go back to get again to
the the brand that the
the slide that shows the allotment in
the middle
at the south the southern end of that
are there houses and things in there i
was just wondering about the
connectivity
or is where which is allotments and
which is anything else
so and the bottom of that
my understanding is that this is the
alumni site and then there is housing
further along to the south it's right
right down there along here yeah so this
so as we were viewing along um
castleton way
coming out of the site that's where you
have
those existing
red brick
pantile dwellings and then further down
you've got the
linear run of semi-detached red brick
dwellings
further down into eye as well
okay well that's all the questions so
we'll move on um
to the next item so we move on to uh
public speakers
um
so first of all we move on to the parish
council and we have richard berry and
andy robertson here
so over to you we have a timer here we
do ask you to please keep to the three
minutes and over to you when you're
ready thank you chairman andy robinson
representing i town council
i town council seeks to ensure that
planning applications in the town meet
the objectives of the i neighborhood
plan which should be identified in the
office of report of power 12.1 as part
of the development plan
indeed as councillors have noted it is
the most up-to-date part of the
development plan
policy i4 of that plan states that land
south of our airfield should remain a
commitment of the plan and shall be
developed for 280 dwellings and a care
home in accordance with the approved
design brief
in this instance the council also seeks
to ensure that the requirements of the
outline plan commission are met
in particular it wishes to ensure that
the site as a whole should not exceed
280 homes or 265 homes on the portion on
which persimmon has an interest
house types and sizes should reflect the
proven need for smaller homes the design
should be of high quality as set out in
the design brief ecology and
biodiversity should be enhanced
how does this application meet these
objectives the number of homes is
consistent with the objective to limit
the total on the persimmon portion to
265
house types are much too weighted
towards larger four and five bedroom
homes
the comments of the district council
strategic housing department confirm the
need identified in policy i3 for one and
three bedroom homes to predominate
design quality has improved during
negotiations but remain a bit short of
the quality
required by the design brief across the
site as a whole
the council agrees with the comments of
place services and the wildlife trust
that the current proposals to enhance
ecology and diversity are
deficient however the council accepts
that substantial progress has been made
to bring the proposals in line with the
i neighborhood plan
and the outline planning commission and
that they are unlikely to be improved
further it has therefore withdrawn its
objection however it places on record
that it wishes to be fully involved in
the plans and proposals to enhance
ecology and biodiversity to ensure the
outline plan permission conditions are
fully met prior to the development
starting
secondly the second phase of the
persimmon site should comprise no more
than 127 homes to ensure a maximum of
265.
house types should be dominated in that
phase by smaller one to three bedroom
homes to ensure that the 265 homes in
phases one and two in aggregate provides
the profile required in
the eye neighborhood plan
and that phase has the highest quality
i've noted during the discussion
chairman uh the concern of members uh
about the second phase and bringing that
balance and i think the town council
would share the concern that there's no
certainty that the second phase will
bring that into balance
in terms of house types
and it would be useful to understand uh
how that more certainty could be
provided
uh and finally uh just a comment last
sentence please yes finally uh the
policy i 25 of the neighborhood plan
does require one charging point per
dwelling
thank you very much for that uh
questions for the town council yep
council password um thanks matthew two
quick questions if i may please um you
commented that you were looking for some
improvements to the design guide
fine could you just try and articulate
what sorts of things you might be
looking at and you said the ecological
report i think if i heard correctly um
or the proposals were deficient could
you just give some examples of what else
you would like to see and hopefully that
can be some sort of negotiation to
rectify them
thank you yes
taking the the second one first uh i i'm
no expert so i i couldn't uh uh give you
a definitive answer to that uh but i
think if you see in terms of the
comments the comments made by play
services as your consultee
and by uh the suffolk wildlife trust
outlines the sorts of provision uh that
should be made uh in in in relation to
that uh in terms of design quality uh i
guess uh if you look at the uh character
area one i think it was where you
entered the the the site clearly much
more effort has been put into that to
create house types and styles uh
different levels different use of
materials the further you go into the
development
thank you um
yeah two
two things perhaps going to the um
yeah the the ecology and landscaping um
issue first
do um
does the town council have any any kind
of systematic
um follow-up
to ensure that the on on any given
development that the
landscaping and ecology requirements uh
are all put in place i mean i think over
the years i've realized that this
council does not have the resources
to really check those things and that
we're very dependent on parishes and
towns to do so so i wondered whether
given the extent of development and and
the efforts of the producing the
neighborhood plan uh you you've actually
got um you've got that actually in mind
chairman yes there is some expertise in
the town council and with the within the
town uh regarding biodiversity and
ecology um and the town council would
like to have discussions uh with the
landowner and developer about the
continued maintenance of the site
once we've achieved a satisfactory
scheme as required by the outlying
condition
we would like to have a discussion about
the town council's role in
ensuring that the uh landscaping uh is
maintained over a longer period of time
thank you one other chair
yeah the the other question this
committee is very um very aware from a
few meetings back
about the issue in of um visitor parking
in the town as a whole
um now i can't quite get my head around
exactly where this
and i think we're probably talking about
the outline and phase two more than
phase one here um whether whether
there's
any scope for for any of this
site outline
uh master plan to contribute to helping
with that problem in terms of you know
whether you can sort of have a tourist
trail or something
that
so that people will come to a car park
that isn't in the middle of town
john
but we can only really talk about the
application that's before us and what's
before us and there isn't a that isn't
in this phase with this application
yeah i mean it's a fight we can't really
commit to having things in phase two but
can you well do you want to see what you
see see where it goes
yes thank you i i i think um one of the
key proposals in the neighborhood plan
is to provide a linkage to this whole
development area uh into the town centre
for cycling and walking
currently the 106 agreement makes no
contribution to that
there is a note in the office of report
regarding potential sill
contribution i'm not sure if that's been
defined yet
but it certainly would be useful to have
some investment as part of this proposal
to ensure that cycling and walking
linkages into the town are improved
to reduce the pressure on car parking in
the town centre
but that's the manslaughter than cancer
yeah of course
could i could i just ask through you
chair that the um people sitting behind
the town council stop conferring because
it's quite off-putting when we're trying
to listen to
the questions what people are saying
thank you one
country man
i i think i think it was me was it me or
counselled really sorry i meant thank
you council event councillor mansell um
thank you um i just wanted to ask about
the extensive open space that's uh
being provided as part of this
application
um which as has been highlighted in our
report
there is currently a deficit of open
space within i and you as a town council
are welcoming the provision of more
public open space
and this may be
not um a question for the town council
but i just wondered if the town council
was considering
taking on that open space or whether it
is going to be
managed by a management company or the
district council or whether you have any
views at all on the extensive open space
and and given that you've just commented
on uh cycle and pedestrian connectivity
to the town
um and i'm a bit um i think that large
semicircular open space um looks like an
ideal opportunity to have an access to
the south and i can't see it on any plan
and i wonder whether you had any views
on that because i can see that as being
a desire line
chair if i if i may answer i'm richard
berry i chair planning for i town
council i i think the the concentration
of the discussion on landscaping and
open space is entirely apt as it's been
so far
it's very much in our view part of the
built environment
and
we would consider given appropriate
resources to take a role in monitoring
and managing that open space as the
development
proceeds we've actually had this
discussion in principle with with
planning officers and i think the phrase
that we said was leave it on the table
this may well be something that the
council could take on i believe those
things are far better dealt with locally
it's very much that it that if it's your
environment and you know something
should be provided you're more likely to
monitor it bring it to the notice of the
relevant authorities so as i said i
would make a caveat then that if you
take something on you need to have the
resources to do it and that's a big
caveat
but that very much figures in
on the radar of the town council
we have a number of other things that we
manage um that we've done in partnership
with the district council so yes i think
i i can say that subject to resources
being forthcoming that is something that
could be considered and i believe better
done locally thank you
thank you
okay
we'll move on then we have no other
questions at the moment so we'll move on
um
we don't have a objector we don't have a
supporter but we do have the agent
robert robert barber and again
uh over to you and you have three
minutes please
thank you chair members uh thank you for
the opportunity to speak in support of
the application i'm rob barber from
pegasus group the planning agent for
persimmon homes some may recall i was
actually involved in the outline
original outline permission as well
we've worked closely with planning
offices at the district council and with
members of the town council to ensure
that this proposal accords with the
outline planning permission the adopted
development brief
and the
neighborhood plan
there have been a number of meetings
during the course of the application
to ensure that all items have been
addressed appropriately
with layout and design changes
arising from those discussions
the officer report and presentation sets
out the full details of the scheme for
your consideration and has usefully
highlighted the scheme's compliance with
those relevant documents and policies
i would also like to set out the
benefits
from the development which can be
summarized as follows
138 dwellings 28 of which are affordable
with the agreement of your own housing
strategy officer
ndss compliance and just to pick up a
point in respect of the the
housing mix
69 percent of the dwellings are in fact
two and three bedroom there is not a
predominance of four and five bedroom
houses
the creation of an integrated and
sustainable residential community
sensitive to the relationship of i and
in in accordance with the outlying
permission
a range of dwelling type sizes and
tenures
delivery of new open spaces for new and
existing residents of the area
the new access from castleton way which
improved connections from development to
the surrounding area
including future proofing for connection
to the referee
which is ipolicy 22.
new pedestrian cycle routes through the
development which complement existing
routes providing sustainable transport
choices including the early provision of
the cycle connectivity to victoria hill
this was originally going to be provided
as part of phase two
the creation of strong landscape
structure
focused around retained vegetation
responding to local area and parking in
accordance with adopted parking
standards with no triplex parking
on site
um we've talked about
other benefits but the the main one is
is a
19 reduction in carbon emissions
set out in
your emerging policy lp 25
achieved through a combination of
measures which is set out in a
sustainability statement which is a
discharge of condition requirement
these include electric electric
charging points to be installed on the
majority of plots and where they can't
be on plot ducting available
in the communal areas
an option for pvs to be offered to
purchasers
is being looked at and explored as part
of the offer
water butts for every house and energy
efficiency improvements through careful
building siting design and orientation
i'm afraid your time is up so i need the
last sentence please okay and we have
addressed all technical matters which
have arisen as part of the planning
application and there are no objections
from outstanding uh consultees
and we look forward to a positive
outcome today thank you
thank you very much uh questions
i'll yeah councilman you get best
uh thank you chair um i've got a couple
of questions one was the one i asked the
uh planning officer um
and i welcome the um
cycle connection to victoria hill but it
also talks about a cycle pedestrian and
emergency vehicle access to haygate
which i think looks to me like it's near
that semi-circular bit of open land
can you confirm that there is going to
be a pedestrian connection there
because i can't see it on the planet it
looks like there's a hedge across the
most obvious point
could i also ask you uh how many homes
you um should you get planning
permission today or you know should we
decide make the determination today how
many of these houses do you um
you know hope to be completed um in the
next four months before june
um
thank you if i take the last one first i
mean clearly
the approval of reserve matters
is only the first of a number of
technical approvals that are required um
i know persimmon are looking to program
commencement of construction this year
but i have no idea in terms of how long
that is likely to take in terms of a a
commencement um that that is out of my
hands
and with persimmon
um
i just in terms of the um
connections
um
there is uh intention and there's always
been an intention to look at the
connection to hey gate
um what i'm not sure about is the legal
ability to do so because of london third
party land ownership control and that is
still being looked at
as i understand it at the moment what we
have done however is create a westward
link from that semi-circular open space
into the existing footpath network which
comes to the south as well so it's
something that is still being
investigated but at the moment that is
something that we we i can't
guarantee can be delivered at this
moment in time
thank you given your aunt the first
answer that you gave
do you think it is a bit short-sighted
not to
move away from gas spoilers
uh given that you're unlikely to finish
that many homes before june when the
regulations have changed
all i can all i can say um and perhaps
my client who i have with me today may
be able to supplement my answer is that
persimmon as a group are looking at all
sorts of technologies moving forward
they are well aware of the changes to
the building rights that are coming
forward um and will will apply
those building ranks as necessary i
don't think they are in a position to
commit to one particular technology at
the moment but
i think it's something that they know is
coming and they will have to comply with
but at this moment in time it is not a
requirement of the building regulations
i just follow up on that particular
point i mean we we have applications
before us every four weeks and
developers come in and say actually
we've now moved away from gas we're
moving on to this they've got a plan
it's only three months away so
how come you don't have a plan as to
whether it's going to be gas or other
technology in such short time
such a short time frame away
yeah sorry i'll if i can just come in
there we we are looking as as a group so
it is being investigated as we speak but
we don't have a final answer on how
we're going to address that at this
stage but it is something we're very
aware of but we're working with the
current building regulations
until such time as um we only see the
building regulations which haven't been
issued yet i haven't seen them myself
yet
and so as we are live to that we are
looking at that and what we'd say is in
terms of the emerging policy we're
offering up nineteen
um over and above the the existing
policy requirements and through that we
are offering photovoltaics
as part of the
the options on this site as well
which um you know in terms of reducing
co2 is a step in the right direction for
i'm sure you'll agree so in terms of
boilers we're working with current
regulations but that will change and we
know it's going to change
just on terms if i can just clarify a
little bit on the deliverability
and
we are all about deliverability at
persimmon um subject to approval today
hopefully we will get an approval we
will be looking to start on the site as
soon as we discharge pre-commencement
conditions
and get a starting site
hopefully in april
and we're looking at first completions
towards the end of this year i think we
could summon the budget for the second
half but it's likely to be november time
for
that i'm going to have to push you a bit
on this so persimmon is a major house
builder in the uk has no plans in place
today as to what it's going to do when
gas boilers end possibly in june this
year is that what you're saying no i'm
not saying that we will have options
available we're exploring all the
options air source heat pumps is one
option to us those ground source heat
pumps there's a number of other things
we can consider but as a group we have
not i'm not in a position today to tell
you what that is because we're exploring
all options
okay
thank you
uh yeah we'll move on i've got
councillor passmore next
thanks so very much chairman um two
points to raise with you you've heard me
mention these before first one if you
look at the um
comments from the suffolk wildlife trust
on page 132 133
would you be happy if we were
to give permission and we delegated the
officers
um
as part of the conditions to
enter into discussion there to look at
the
some of the improvements they suggest
there for example hedgehog fences swift
boxes
um etc because i think any
good developer we have had other
developers here who have been very happy
to do that and i think you get a lot of
public approval for that so i think
that's the first thing and the other
comment i just want to clarify my
suggestions regarding the i suppose it's
the permeability of driveways we live in
the driest part of the country and we
want to try and minimize
without being too pedantic and zealot
like um that actually porous driveways
are far better if that can be arranged
and again if that were to go through
that would something i would like to see
delegated to the office to discuss with
you so i'm just really asking very
simply would you be happy to um or agree
to enter discussions on
um
that
i think i can found
more than happy to enter discussions on
both of those points just in terms of
the porosity of the the driveways um any
system that is designed around a
subsystem and this is a subsystem um
will have permeability into the ground
in any event so even if the driveways
themselves weren't porous they would be
fed into us a subsystem that would
eventually feed back into the ground
water so
but it by doing that
the water is cleaned off the drives
through the system that it goes through
so it's it's not that it won't be
necessarily even if the driveway's on
for us because that is a really big
important issue for us here in there and
that's understandable
yeah i understand persimmon already in
in discussions with anglia water and the
local flood authority okay thank you
very much
thanks councilman
he's gone off that
good thank you
um
yeah
yeah obviously i'm unhappy about the you
your guests um
you know what i'm gonna say john no
views at this stage it's just no no all
right thank you right my question i have
the question my question is
um
giving your reluctance in that direction
to the chair um
could you perhaps commit to to making a
hundred percent underfloor heating um at
this stage as that is more and more
efficient and would lend itself better
to um
to to
future uh air source heat pump
approaches i think we just got to be
careful where we're going on this let me
just bring in the officer just because
it's you know what we can and can't ask
for
yeah um i mean the mppf is really clear
on this um where something's dealt with
by another regime we shouldn't be
looking to impose ourselves and
generally as well within planning
we're interested in the creation of
places and spaces we aren't as
interested in the internal
build of the house that is that is the
remit of building regs
and if building regulations would allow
you to construct a property without 100
underfloor heating within it
um then that is what building regs would
allow you to do now obviously we've got
updated building rigs coming out in due
course and there might be changes within
it at that point but
at this point it might not be we might
not
we might be overreaching ourselves to be
able to uh
ask for a condition to say we would like
100 underfloor heating within
phase one
i mean it will probably be something
that persimmon will be looking at in any
event once they've settled on a
heating solution because obviously we
are looking at air source or ground
source underfloor heating is more
conducive to that but if they looked at
another system and we've already tied
them
in we might not be able to get the best
efficiency out of that system if we've
already said but we need undersource
heating
okay so we'll move on from that one john
if you've got anything else i'll move on
to councillor mansell
i've asked my questions
um thank you very much
thank you um gentlemen for your comments
um
the housing mix um
in your um
comments just now you talked about
joining you know connecting two and
three bedrooms as in the centers of
total but we're particularly interested
in two-bedroom only
um so would you be prepared to look at
increasing that amount of two-bedroom
homes on this site currently it's 18.8
percent
um which is a
huge odds to the eye neighborhood plan
figure of 53
um
and if you know it has been suggested
that could be amended across phase two
but that would mean 89 of the homes on
phase two would be two-bedroom so i
can't see that happening um so would you
be prepared to up that figure for the
two-bedroom because i think we're it's
particularly about people downsizing
local people buying a home
it's it's not all about people working
from home so would you prepare to change
that thank you very much
thank you
the issue of the housing mix was
discussed uh at length in the
discussions that we've had on um uh
phase one uh the seminar fully aware of
the requirements of eye policy uh in
relation to one and two beds
how that plays out in terms of phase two
i i have no idea because i'm not
instructed uh in that respect
what i would say though and it's
something uh the counselor on your right
sorry your name escapes me for the
moment um did allude to in his question
um
that rose that
if if you um the the town council are
very keen on ensuring that the
maximum number of dwellings is 265 on
this foot on this element
if you increase the number of two
bedrooms
uh properties you actually reduce the
land take
and what you end up with is a disparity
between
the the land and the number of dwellings
and you end up with surplus land
um now that isn't an efficient use of
land that isn't um now that that's a
that's a discussion that we've had and
we will probably come back to at some
point but it's not our intention at this
moment to exceed that number that's not
what we're here to do what we're trying
to do is balance all of the issues of
design
character landscape and open space
within a scheme that is
acceptable and meets that balance
and we we will revisit that when we come
to start to look at in detail phase two
please do um
thank you very much sir i'm a bit
confused by the answer because our
neighbourhood plan was made in may was a
referendum may 2021 so um
you know that's
coming up for you know nine months ago
or so
um so these these figures and indeed mid
suffix figures of of what the housing
need is up to 2036 i think mid suffix
one is 34
two bed eyes was 53
so those figures have been in the public
domain for a long time before you know
this has come to committee so i i i
would really ask that you
you know revisit that figure and
um
you know that yes the housing is a total
but that's you know we've known that i i
i understand the point you're making but
the corollary to that is that the
outline permission was given at a time
when uh
had we had those figures
it may have been a different
outcome
okay thank you
uh your colleague from persimmon doesn't
want to come in on that point at all
because you said you didn't have any
information on it do you have any
information on the points raised i i
don't have anything to add to what mr
barber has already said i think he's
covered all the the points that i would
make thank you
thank you uh
thank you chairman um i asked a question
earlier about the east side
boundary of the allotment gardens and
the future of the pond and the trees in
there could you um enlighten me please
yes happy to do so
my understanding is that that that pond
actually stays
and i think it forms part of the
um site-wide drainage strategy
could i come back it's not in any of the
drainage plans
that i could find
i'll need to take that away and double
check that but my understanding was that
it it
formed part of that strategy but i'll
take that away and have a look
okay thank you
councillor mayor
can you confirm that the spine roads
will be built to adoptable standards
and if so that they will be offered to
the county council for adoption
that's my understanding yes
thank you councillor
thank you sorry to return to the
building rigs
uh one of the pacific
rep could tell me
our house is
built to the building rigs as they exist
at the point of approval
reserve matters approval perhaps or are
they built to the building rigs that
exist at the time of construction
i believe it's at a time of construction
so whatever regulations are available at
that time once their construction has
commenced that's the building rigs that
we would um build out to
thank you
that's been confirmed by ian de prez as
well
okay any more questions for the
applicant
nope okay so we'll now move on to the
ward member
peter gould is unable to be here today
so i'll read out his statement
my apologies for not being able to
attend development control committee for
its consideration this important
application i know that the town council
will be speaking to the committee and
will address many of the points that i
would otherwise make
the suitability of this site for
substantial housing development was
accepted in the town some time ago
and proposals have evolved over a number
of years initially through the place
shaping work
and then as a key allocated site in the
i neighborhood plan
the i neighborhood plan was approved at
referendum in may last year with
substantial majority and support
as you'll see from the report the town
council has been very involved in
renegotiating the scheme over recent
months as a result the application
better reflects the design brief agreed
when outline consent was given though
there remains some tension between local
aspirations in terms of housing design
and the standardized approach of a
national house builder
i am sure that members of the committee
will give heed to the comments made by
the town council in its november 2021
submission
which while finding no grounds to object
to this application reflects key points
and policies in the i neighborhood plan
issues of sustainability and
connectivity have been key to the town
council's support for the application
i can confirm that my colleague
councillor jessica fleming and i are in
discussion with officers about support
for the development of environmental
projects in i including those identified
in the town council submission
approval for this application represents
a significant step in delivery of the i
neighborhood plan and i hope the
committee will give it approval peter
gould
okay members so that's all the
information before us it's now up to us
to discuss debate and reach
sorry
i was going to take a break at half past
when we're two hours in
you need one okay
we're happy to accommodate can i ask
that there's absolutely no discussion
about the application please
and we'll start again in 10 minutes
okay so welcome back everyone so we've
obviously uh heard all the information
put before us um and it's now up to us
to discuss
and to come to a conclusion
so over to members really
who wants to kick it off
how's it possible right yeah i've just
just for a change thank you thank you
chairman well um this is quite an
interesting application well aware of
course that the um outline permission is
being granted this is just for reserve
matters
um
and i think on balance having heard
um what has been said by people i'm
actually going to
um propose
approval but i've got various conditions
i would like to put down of course
that's up to everybody else to agree and
i'm happy to take additions to that if
necessary so
um we did ask the agent and one of some
of the conditions here i do urge them to
continue discussions um with the
officers
and the town council on the design guide
we really want high quality developments
in mid-suffolk i'm not saying this isn't
but if there are ways of working
together to improve it so we can have a
development that we're all proud of
and i think that's what we really want i
do know i very well it is an historic
ancient borough and we want to make sure
any development up there complements it
properly not just stuck in there so um
that's the first one
i am a little bit concerned but i think
the agent and the developer said they
are prepared to have discussions um
about improving the ecology and
mitigation
as per the letter in the papers there
with the suffolk wildlife trust again
i'd like the officers if i may um to
take that as a delegated um condition to
deal with that
the permeability of the driveways i just
want to make sure we've got belt and
braces on that i think you all know
where i'm coming from and i think a lot
of other members of the committee are
it's not about being pedantic or getting
down to exact details but making sure we
are doing everything we possibly can
to preserve our very scarce natural
water resources
in one of the driest parts of the
country
with that ecology mix i think james you
mentioned about the pond there seems to
be we need some certainty about the pond
and its retention so if that could be
added in as well again um discussions
there
there's been a lot of discussion about
phase two we can't do anything about
phase two i just wonder whether it might
be helpful there's an element of trust
here and i'm sure personally we'll be
coming back with other applications of
the future
we need to make sure
that the overall planning conditions
that were given
the outline with the right housing mix
endures all the way through i absolutely
understand the town council
and those on the periphery and working
towards the center but that's just done
on trust
we can't condition that but i would like
to add a pretty strong advisory note to
make sure
everybody understands this committee is
not just waving it through not ignoring
that and i think that's the way to do it
because we can't actually debate
um phase two so that's in the spirit of
cooperation trust and working together
and that's it thank you
well i just asked philip just to comment
on the
the
two sites and the point that council
passed away just raised about you know
what stamp can we put on this
uh thank you yes so um
you have an outline permission which was
granted before a plan was made so you've
got to you've got to affect your tension
in the sense that people will do
land deals to
anticipate a certain sort of development
and that starts to commit their hand in
terms of what they expect
nonetheless you've got a statutory duty
to
consider this application against the
development plan the i neighborhood plan
is part of the development plan i3 deals
with mix
like most planning policies you cannot
have an absolute hard line there must
always be scope for consideration of
facts on the ground
and i3 talks about alternative mix being
only permitted where evidence is brought
forward that demonstrates
that that mix is not viable or
deliverable
you also don't have the complete picture
of this development at this point so
if you were to try and pursue the
question you've got
more questions about what this scheme
actually amounts to in totality
and from my perspective councillor
pasmore's approach of an informative
seems to me
that shot across the bows to say there
is an expectation of this
and that by the time the details for the
rest of this development come back in
front of you
you will be able to market against that
and draw a conclusion
clearly the town council right from the
outset of this application have
expressed concern that this policies is
um
uh is a question mark uh unresolved
you've heard what the applicant has to
say about that this morning
from my perspective the informative
approach
puts down your marker
that you are alive to the plan and know
what it should expect
and
i would
anticipate that by the time you get a
revised
a supplementary application for that
further phase
that you will either have an application
that meets that policy or that very
clearly demonstrates why it is not
viable or deliverable which is
expected within the terms of the policy
itself so
um
i have heard the conversation about mix
i think
what you have is a pragmatic solution
which doesn't pull any punches german
um thank you very much chair um firstly
um i just want to highlight the eye
neighborhood plan um
this is the most recent
part of the adopted development plan
despite it not being
um mentioned at 12.1 in our papers
um and um we we as a as a committee as a
planning authority should be taking that
as our first port of call
it's the most recent and um
has only been through a referendum
in may 2021
and it does provide an awful lot of
detail about what the residents of i
would expect to see
um i appreciate this um development as
reserve matters and it is um already got
outline permission
and
i think the
internal landscaping of the site is is
good and i'm pleased to see the variety
of open spaces the amount of trees and
so forth um i assumed that on the
conditions that various ecology matters
such as swift boxes and so and so forth
are
will be in use
however i would like to see a
um
or to be assured that the
northern boundary of hedging trees and
so forth is one planted in advance which
we never seem to get of a development
starting so that it is actually doesn't
take five years for um
those residents to feel the impact of it
in relation to the
industrial area to the north
so i would like some reassurance on that
whether that comes through conditions or
not i'm not sure
i think it's rather disappointing and
i'm sorry to say from persimmon that the
whole issue about gas boilers we've got
an application later on today from a
large house builder with um air source
heat pumps i mean we see many with air
source heat pumps with different types
of um
of ways of um meeting their
our climate um change emissions
objectives and it's just it is very
disappointing that it's not there's
there's no foresight there and um
i find that very very surprising and i'd
be quite interested if they were to you
know send details to the council in due
course of what they are planning to do
um in general really so that's
disappointing um
however you know in terms of designs of
the actual housing housing itself um
you know that seems to have been an
improvement on what was first put
forward and again
um our neighborhood plan have made
comments about the design in line with
what they've suggested but the thing
that i'm really not happy about is the
housing mix
the
we need two bedroom homes there are 18.8
percent of these homes are going to be
two-bedroom and that's against our
neighborhood plans ask a 53 percent and
our own of 34 there's only half is half
of what mid suffolk are asking for in
two bedroom homes now those figures
we've known about
um for a long time and um
i can't see that it's been demonstrated
as the um chief planning officer said in
terms of the viability or the it's kind
of anecdotal um
in terms of not being able to provide
two-bedroom homes and in fact the
you know there's the comments about
working from home in order to kind of
push up the figure of three-bedroom
homes
but we need houses for people to
downsize into so people and i can who
are living in big homes and want to
downsize and stay an eye people in
surrounding villages you want to
downsize can move into and that is what
what we need so i am
disappointed about the housing mix and i
think that that should have been
considered far more up front in terms of
this and
given again i say that our neighbourhood
plan is the most recently adopted part
of the development plan that is what
should hold sway thank you chair
thank you very much councillor
matt
yeah thank you mike i'm i'm with you
again
um
yeah can i just ask councillor ebon to
repeat the percentage
of two bed
homes that would be required in phase
two in order to to achieve the um the
overall
mix across the two
did you want to keep going
madison or come back to you okay
councilman
uh thank you chair um
yeah i i'll try not to repeat um what my
fellow um counselor eberlas just said
but i i i do agree with all that she has
said um and um with all the best will in
the world and a whole host of
informatives
i just can't see phase two coming
through with 89 two-bedroom houses um no
doubt we will be
given lots of evidence at that stage
about why it's unviable
so i think it is incredibly
disappointing that we have so few
two-bedroom town homes in this phase one
of this development um i also um think
that given that our neighbourhood plan
is the most up-to-date um planning
policy document that we have
and i believe that says that electric
vehicle charging points should be on all
new homes and we only have ducting here
so um
i think that that would that would be
something that i would like to see
on all the properties um and i think
that is if i've read our neighborhood
plan correctly that is part of the
policy there
um
and um i i'm also um i'm sorry to help
on about it um i would like an
informative about carrying on the
discussion about a pedestrian access to
what hey gate was it called haygate
which i believe the agent said that they
were trying to negotiate but there was a
land permission
thing um that they couldn't guarantee it
but
um i think that that would be
a a good way to for
existing residents of i to access that
large tract of open space that is coming
alongside this development which
i think is is great actually it looks
like you know lots of footpaths and open
space
and a link from one side of the town to
the other for pedestrians um so that the
residents of this new development don't
feel cut off from the rest of the town
and they can walk in lots of different
ways do a circular route rather do their
shopping in the middle of town or
whatever
the more pedestrian connectivity we can
build into this to the existing um
network of roads and footpaths the
better
but i too like councillor ebern do have
my doubts about the housing mix i am
concerned about the the low number of
two-bedroom dwellings
on this site and also the um ev charging
i think needs to be updated and i think
in fact i'm a bit baffled by this
developer who has said that they're
unlikely to finish their property their
first properties they're hoping to
complete by november that's after this
june
um
date when we've been promised the new
building regs and yet they say oh we're
going to put gas boilers in the ones
that are completed before them well it
sounds like there aren't going to be any
so
um you know why haven't they got
something in plan for those houses that
they're going to finish by the end of
this year that will not be compliant
with the building reg should this new
document come out so
there are a couple of anomalies but on
the whole i think they've done a lot of
work the layout looks okay
and they have thought about some things
and improve the design um but i'll i'll
wait to hear what other people say
whether we can put any more pressure on
them uh to get
more of what we want thank you
next that was councillor casten
thank you very much mr chairman um yeah
i agree with a lot the council the past
morom said and he um he mentioned the
pond in there which i was quite
um pleased about i think we need to be
um quite robust in asking for that pond
to be kept because i get the feeling
we're not gonna get anything that we
don't absolutely fall through with this
one
um but that's a personal opinion the um
there's a good green area on here it is
disappointing the um the housing mix
for me that isn't enough i that's not a
big enough reason here to say that this
isn't an acceptable plan
the um
the charging points
i am i don't know how environmentally
friendly it is to um ship over copper
from south america and aluminium from
australia to put pipes in to um to put
cables in to eb charging points that may
never be used or could be superseded
reasonably quickly for me i think that's
bad for the environment and that's a lot
of carbon that could just sit in a duct
for the whole time
and never be used that worries me that
for me if if the committee really wants
those cables in
that
that's not a massive issue for me but
the thing that really
worries me a little bit with this is as
you enter this development
you um
on the outside you've got the um foul
pumping
um building you can't see it on this
some site outlet outline
because it's it's cut off but in the
proper site on the left hand side as you
drive in you've got the um foul pumping
station
and that to me really urbanizes this
development
can we put a little bit of
landscaping and just mitigate the impact
of that it might be a beautiful building
but it probably won't be so could we
just put something in to mitigate the
impact of that um
that foul pumping station on the
left-hand side as you as you enter
please but i'm i'm i'm happy to second
um councillor pasmore's um
um
um proposal um i do i would be
interested to see what councils think
about that um okay well we'll pick up
those points um counselor mayor
thanks jim um
i think there's
much about this development that i like
and i particularly like the fact that
the
parish council sorry the town council
the developer have engaged um
together and changes have been made
i find housing mix baffling
why is a developer would you
front load phase one with the potential
that you could be forced to deliver
two bed houses in phase two which which
may not be profitable um
strange
but having listened to mr isabel um
that's
outside the remit of this committee and
i think an informative is the best we
can do
i do hope that phase two comes back
before this committee in the future
recharges i think we need to be a little
bit careful about electric charges as i
understand it different cars require
different charges
i would prefer to see notwithstanding
what my colleague said i would prefer to
see the electoral installation installed
to the distribution level
and then owners can put their own
charges
that they need for their particular
vehicle putting in a standard charger
that might just be ripped out in the
future doesn't seem to make sense to me
but yeah notwithstanding the um
issues around two bedroom houses i i
will support this application
thank you that's everyone that wants to
speak so i'll just make hey you want to
come back
yes i did i just wanted to get that 89
in front of us
all again as i wasn't i couldn't quite
believe when i heard it before and i
thought she said yeah 89
yeah the
the problem to me is yet the mix is that
even if we
get
50 or 60 percent
two-bedroom houses in phase two to shift
the thing nearer to what the eye
neighborhood plan says
um we then we're then actually creating
a social issue
in the the lack of diversity that you
you would have in in the second phase
and so you know i've really really don't
quite think i can actually support this
i mean yeah there's a
you can see it's a really nice um
application a lot of effort has been put
into
to
how the thing looks
and and we're going to get a bit more on
the ecology hopefully than than is
with us so far
and yes the connectivity lots of nice
things but it is just
too far away from
what is our
development plan which is the eye
neighbourhood plan
mix
thank you
uh casterfield you want to go next
now i spare you the long speech um
my feeling really is uh the the thought
that this will be built to the june of
july building rex is um
a great improvement just what they carry
we don't know
but at least it's got to be better than
we have now
i sort of remain in hope that sometime
persimmon will negotiate a good price
for ground source or air source heat
pumps with someone and get on with it um
and we'll leave that like that i am
pleased to see er installation of uh
points for electric charges to be
connected i am inclined to think putting
the ducts in is the critical part of the
job pulling cables into them is a
low-cost exercise that can be done when
you wish
ensuring that there's adequate capacity
in houses to supply such devices is
vital
redoing the low voltage network would be
extremely expensive so that seems to
meet
those requirements so i'm very happy on
that and obviously the comments about
the general appearance and things
i go along with
i have to say i'm a little concerned
about
failing to me the iron neighbourhood
plan
quantity of houses the the size split
although i have to say that i sit here
i was trying to think if i'd known
anybody who has ever downsized and i
suppose
yeah 20 years ago my father did
so i do know one person but it is a
concept that i sometimes wonder why we
pedals quite so hard
so i'm inclined to agree
that i could go along with the
application as it is
and
rely on phase two to put numbers right
if we need to do that thank you
thanks i think i'm the only one that
hasn't given a view um
i i also share the concerns of the town
council
in terms of the mix and
it is
i go along i think i use the name was
casamayors i am baffled because
um
you know it it
it would be so simple just to deliver a
little bit better than going to these
sorts of numbers up front which then
leaves what is going to be a problem in
the next application i mean we all know
it's going to happen but we can't talk
about the next application because it's
not before us but
you know i think we're storing up a
problem for that
i'm also
slightly bemused we have applications
before us from major house builders
virtually every two weeks or every four
weeks
and and this council meets every two
weeks with planning applications and i i
can't remember if we've ever had a
national house bill to come in still
unsure as to how they're going to
heat the housing especially when the the
building rugs are only going to change
in four months time
so again that again slightly
baffles me
um it's not what we'd normally expect at
the committee
in terms of the
ecology
what i would ask is that this site is an
exemplar for ecology what i'm very
nervous of is if you drive into
framingham where the trees were planted
there are four trees on the road and
they've now reached about two and a half
meters after four years and you can't
actually see a tree
so i think i take councillor
ebern's point you know early planting is
critical because it takes a long time
for that to grow so if we can do
anything in terms of early planting
to actually help the site feel that
they're you know it's just actually see
the ecology improve so if if there's
anything we can do for it to be an
exemplar i'd be really happy i agree
with the town council i think we should
have electric charging points on every
house
um
i drive a hybrid i come here i sit next
to three other four other five other six
other different electric cars in the car
park we can all plug in there are i know
it's different speed of charging but the
actual plug itself is pretty universal
so i would again agree i think we should
have electric charging points at every
property but i hear my colleagues don't
necessarily agree with that but that's a
personal view so those are the points so
i'll support it but i've got to say it's
pretty begrudgingly i don't think this
is an example of how applications should
be brought to this committee and i am
disappointed with it but i think an
informative just about gets over the
line but it is a very just
so anyone else wish to speak otherwise
what i'll do is i'll ask can i ask you
to round up
what's in the recommendation with all
the additional points please phil
thank you chairman if i can check what
counselor passmore is cancer password i
thought was quite open-minded about what
he'd be prepared to accommodate
um so it would be useful just
to just to check what's what's on on the
table and so if we deal with a mixed
question first of all
um what i'd suggest having her debate is
a note on the following terms so this is
an informative to add to the decision
notice the committee note that the i
neighborhood plan expects a housing mix
set out in policy i3 which is not yet
demonstrated to have been met with this
reserve matters application for this
phase the committee will expect further
phases of this development to
demonstrate that those further phases
accord with that development plan policy
so that the overall mix across the
outline permitted site accords with the
development plan including the
requirements of i3 of the neighborhood
development plan
so um i can uh
and the applicant is here and i will
have a conversation after this in
relation to this but that was what i
would suggest to you uh
councillor
uh then there was the question of the
ecological conditions where i think
picked up from page 52 of the papers and
the recommendation regarding swift nest
nest boxes and hedgehogs
and i'd suggest a condition which is
effectively a further scheme of
ecological on-plot enhancements to
include the installation of swift nest
boxes and hedgehog permeable boundaries
to be agreed
together with the timetable relative to
occupation
and then in relation to permeable
driveways very straightforward there's
actually quite a lot of hard surfacing
not just driveways
there are connected footwears and piles
here so i think i would suggest to pick
up your point in its totality
effectively we're looking looking at a
scheme of permeable driveways and hard
surfacing across the site to be agreed
and
then i i did hear counselor ebay and
talk about landscaping delivering i
don't know how much the proposal the
motion which is to go with that but
um so perhaps if i'm going to ask that
question whether i've got that right so
far
um there if everybody agrees i mean you
mentioned matthew making an exemplar and
i agree and i know exactly where you're
talking about in framingham it's so
stark it looks like a lunar landscape
when you move in so good mature tree
planting looking after them a really
good robust scheme as i said and others
have said something that we could be
really proud of and you know i'd like
some views in there from the town
council as well because they don't want
just a and i'm not saying it would be a
blot on the landscape but there's a risk
when we do these things and then i get
fed up and i'm not saying this will
happen here
so-called enforcement of these
conditions you see two little whips of
trees about three feet tall you know
this is where a bit of imagination needs
so it really does make a difference and
the report i was referring to as per the
suffolk wildlife trust i'm sure they've
got views they put in their letter there
so
we don't need to write it all down but i
think that's the spirit of it making a
a a scheme that we are all proud of
involving the suffolk wildlife trust and
the town council and i think that would
would cover it but you obviously get the
gist of what everybody's been saying
council rebound do you want to come in
um thank you chair um councillor would
you would you be happy to put advanced
planting in say say
mentioning the advanced planting because
particularly around that edge where
you're not gonna yeah so that it gets
going in advance
thank you
i'll try projecting a little further um
so i think where we got to with that
because i wasn't with the pond point um
what we're talking about is i think a
scheme of landscaping ecological
mitigation and enhancement timetabling
so we've got the landscaping details
we've got the planting plans we have
that within the bundle at the moment but
this is about the timetabling of it
across the site to be agreed which shall
in particular require the planting of
the northern boundary of the site not
later than the commencement of
construction because obviously this is a
development that happened over time and
i don't know whether that does or
doesn't pick up on councillor ebern's uh
interest and whether the northern
boundary was the focus or whether it's
it's wider than that
i think it will say wider where possible
yes please because because if framingham
is a classic example there are four
trees that are after five years are
three three meters tall if you're lucky
and they don't you can't see them
and i would hesitate to use the word
common sense but have we said here
but seriously you're now on on a point
because
it is about making a scheme we can be
proud of and i think if you get the
spirit of that that's what we would all
expect
and i know the town council and the
developers are here you heard it all
here and i don't want anybody coming
five miles down the road and giving me a
hearing say what the hell are you guys
doing so no i mean we the common sense
should prevail in this we know what we
all need we all know what we're talking
about please do it and make sure that
it's something that is really really
excellent
anything else you want to add um
chairman i'm still wait i'm still i
still need help on the pod so the pond
at the back yeah cancer casting
um yeah well i'd like to see a focus on
the pond for biodiversity to um see it
protected kept or
improved
um that includes the um
the water coming into it not cut off or
however it might be a spring i don't
know but i'd like to see the
um officers just look at that quite
closely and just keep that maintain that
biodiversity
point in this development
okay thank you and casa madison
yeah i just wanted to help mr isabel
with
the suffolk wildlife trust is on page
132
and um also that i think since they
wrote this letter which was in march uh
last year um i think house marty's have
joined swifts in the in the um
in the family of of species that are
increasingly at risk ambulance whatever
it is um so house martin cups is the
phrase which i'm sure mr passmore will
agree to he will
as well as the swifts and the hedgehogs
and the skylarks
right so do you just want to run through
that for us before we go to a vote
please
uh so chairman we've got the informative
and i uh i think i've talked you through
that previously um we've got a condition
which is to uh require a scheme of
on-plot enhancements to include the
installation of swift
and house martin nest boxes
stroke cups
and hedgehog hedgehog permeable
boundaries to be agreed scheme
permeable driveways and hard surfacing
to be agreed
and then a scheme of landscape and
ecological mitigation and enhancement
timetabling across the site to be agreed
which shall in particular require the
planting and boundaries of the site not
later than the commencement of
construction
um and i think that chairman is as far
as i'd got to with this also the water
features sorry i was i haven't quite
finished that
and a scheme to safeguard existing water
features across the site to be agreed
chairman
i did feel that the committee wanted to
do something on the ev charging
points um i personally didn't but i did
get the i did get the feeling the
committee wanted to the proposer and
seconder
i'm happy to accept a proposal for that
but
i mean our policy is that we should have
ev charging points at every property i
thought that was our policy
is that is that correct
uh chairman i think again we look we
look to our neighborhood plan and i've
got currently got that on screen at the
moment um
we do have an application the outline
commission includes a requirement to
submit an energy strategy
um which could perhaps include this
um
this is something that you can delegate
to officers to take away if you like
because uh clearly there is a
recommendation includes adding
conditions as need be
um and i think the alternative is to
impose to add a further informative that
there's an expectation that
you know we look to optimize that
against the policy in um
uh in the eye neighborhood plan so
i think the point is the courtyard
parking if that's where you have to park
and there's no charging then you're
you've got a problem so that's why we
need to just make sure everyone has
access to the ev charge and rather than
those that just have garages
okay uh councillor mansell and then
we'll go to that i think
i i read that the courtyard parking was
the bit that was going to have ducting
there was going to be ducting to every
you know ev every
dwelling would have ducked into one
parking place so i assumed that that
included the um courtyard parking um and
i assumed ducting was just a channel
underground
not including wiring
which
is different but i don't know what the i
neighborhood and whether it's abducting
or wiring
so on this point then i think we'll go
back to philip and we'll just agree the
wording
just i'm just looking at policy i i
policy 25 and it's very clear about
um having um ev charging for dwellings
with off-road parking and give specific
saying if you've got communal parking
what that should be if you've got new
you know whatever so it's not saying
that if you've got
okay so we go within the within the we
need to just follow the policy yeah
they've assumed that obviously if you're
in a courtyard parking that's going to
be a different circumstance so if we
could follow that be easier to thought
yeah okay so on that basis i i what's it
called i
i 25 policy i 25.
sorry chairman we adding a condition an
informative one no we're just expecting
that that will be followed
i think
okay so council passport council cast
and you're happy that we go to the vote
on that basis
okay so over to you
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress in your app
councillor field thank you
i'm having some trouble could i vote
verbally please
four thank you
hasn't come through to me yet
shall i take yours verbally for now
there it is thank you
sorry chair that's five folks four and
three against
okay
thank you very much
that's 543 against
okay thank you very much um can i just
ask people who are moving chairs to do
that now so we can bring in the next
speakers
uh
foreign
okay
folks so the next application before us
is agenda item 8b
which is dc204067
which again is uh in i and we'll hand
over to
sorry
don't worry
let me
see move seats uh hand over to the case
officer me over to you
okay
thank you chairman
so this application follows on um well
from the previous um previous
application this application is for 15
dwellings sorry i we really can't hold
two conversations
sorry
thanks
okay about
you so again members will be quite
familiar with um the overall site for
development
on the eye airfield
which we've obviously discussed with the
main town of i in this location here the
i air fields to the north and the a140
with yaxley to the west
so this is the site of this
current application
which is located in the northeast corner
of
the airfield site with the access of
langton grove
so again looking at the overall
development for the outline application
which is edged in red
the site you've previously been
discussing had that access from
castleton way
and this current scheme
takes access of langton grove
again just for reference the persimmon
site you've just been discussing is
edged in red
the intervening parcel of land is shown
here edged in blue which
is the future
phase that that we've been talking about
and this current application for 15
dwellings is further to the north so
there's no immediate connectivity
between the application that's before
you now
and the ones that you've previously been
discussing
so looking at the constraints map again
it's all probably quite familiar to you
the network of footpaths um throughout
the site but not on this particular
application site which is up here in the
northeast corner
listed buildings we have got the um the
mulberry bush nursery which is near to
the site and a cottage just there off
langton grove otherwise they're really
concentrated in the centre of eye and
its conservation area
again this was touched on this is the
high pressure gas main
area but there's no objection
from
the protection in terms of the impact
on the planning application
again just for reference
the indicative master plan
so parcel 15 is this area in the north
east of the site
where the current application is
centered doesn't cover the whole of the
site and we're talking about 15
dwellings in this application and the
site is actually a bit of an l shape so
there is a bit of a departure from this
indicative master plan although the
principles are generally followed
the blue star there is the proposed care
home
which in
taking into account the the current site
boundaries that care home would actually
be likely to be located in this area
here
you can see um the green way through the
site
um and
the current application
involves a um
uh
the net the car park nursery for the
mulberry bush which is to be well and at
the moment is positioned in this
location here although it was in the
indicative master plan just across the
other side of the road
and this is the very similar plan from
the
development brief
so i'm afraid the plans are orientated
the other way around but here is the
access coming in off langton grove
this position here is the um
restructured mulberry bush nursery car
park with um a sort of plastic sheeting
to enable grass to grow
through and then the roadway continues
round leading to
private drives
at the end so the development brief
did specifically mention that this
parcel of land would have an edge of
settlement character
with detached properties interspersed
with landscaping
this
layout
shows boundary
hedging new native planting to
all of the boundaries
enhancing some of the existing hedgerow
planting which exists in this location
here
we've got a mix of three four and five
bedroom properties on this part of the
site as i say the development brief
envisaged that they would all be
detached properties
the scheme was amended
during consideration so that these
properties here are all single story
and there's an 18 meter buffer zone
identified there to protect the immunity
of these houses in buffy close
so we've got houses in buffy close here
these are
properties in langton grove
this is a barn which has permission for
conversion to two dwellings
and these properties here are in baldwin
close
this is the landscaping proposal which
just gives a bit more detail in terms of
some there is some existing
trees
marked on the site um but enhanced
boundary planting
is proposed and roadside
trees
to create a sort of avenue
context for the development
so the house types the materials are a
mix of red and gray pen tiles
render and brickwork
and we have a mix as i say of three four
and five properties
including bungalows and
dwellings
again to pick up some of the discussion
from the previous application each
property has solar panels shown
each property has electric charging
points and there are three charging
points shown in the nursery car park
the
applicant has submitted a sustainability
statement
but there is a condition on the outline
which would look at some of the we'll
look at these features in more detail
so i'll just flick through these
so it has picked up some of the features
um which are mentioned in the
development brief
um which is to have features such as
chimneys
and um
brick header and sill detailing
and local materials
garages where they're proposed are black
weatherboarding
so each plot is actually individually
designed
i'll just go through these to give you
an indication
so to put the site in its context
this is the access into langtong grove
from the main road which then leads into
i
and the grass verges here
are the existing visibility displays
which are mentioned
in the highways comments
but that has been conditioned as on the
outline
permission
this is the visibility display looking
north
out of
i town center and looking in towards the
footpath linking through
to
the town
these are the houses in bothy close
which i mentioned which back onto that
northeast corner of the site
so this is then the way into
into the site through langtong grove you
can see the character of the existing
properties which bound the site
and this is the other listed building
that i mentioned in langtong grove
so we're now heading in towards the um
towards the site and and the nursery car
park these are houses in baldwin close
and looking back this is the barn that's
got permission for conversion and then
the site comes off to the left
the bit of greenery here
represents the start of the greenway
leading into the site
which you can then see here the nursery
parking on the left and the access into
the site with
so this is the nursery car park
the greenway leading into the site with
the existing farm buildings and the wind
turbines beyond which have been
referenced earlier
this is the eastern site boundary
the rear of the properties in langtong
grove
the site boundary along here
this again really shows the the level
nature of the land this is looking back
towards the car park and these are the
rear of the properties in bossy clothes
where there is an 18 meter
buffer zone and the proposed dwellings
are single story to protect immunity
there
this is the northern boundary of the
site
and this is the very southwestern corner
which links then on to that second
parcel of land that we've been talking
about
chairman picking up on some of the
comments which were previously raised
in terms of landscaping we have got
native trees and hedges
proposed
and we could take on the notion of the
early planting of the boundary
the boundaries in particular if members
felt so inclined private drives are
permeable
each property is electric charging point
and three provided in the nursery car
park
and there is an indication of
the pedestrian and cycle route
continuing into this next parcel of land
in this location here
and in the recommendation i have
suggested that there should be some more
detail
provided to show exactly where that
route would go
and if further discussions are taking
place with the adjacent developer then
that can all be taken into account
again as previously mentioned there's a
number of conditions which uh still need
to be cleared from the outline
permission
um so
details of the surface water drainage um
is one such condition and there's been a
lot of negotiation on this application
with the flood authority and they're
generally happy with the layout um but
we're just like further details to be
agreed by condition
the scheme
is within the
general principles of the neighborhood
plan the development brief uh the
character
that was envisaged for this particular
area and the recommendation is of
approval as on page 193
thank you
thank you very much
okay i guess you can imagine the
questions we'll have is the heating
sources
and triple parking
yeah the indication from the developer
is that the properties would have air
source heat pumps
um they've all got as i mentioned the
solar panels um but the exact details
would come forward
on the condition for an energy uh
strategy
uh there's no triple parking thank you
very much
okay i've got a bunch of pounds of
ground council ebony you were first
um thank you very much chair thank you
charles that presentation um could you
just put slide i think was 58 probably
the last one actually up
um and could you just confirm that the
care home
will now be in
where that's going to be i presume it's
that right that white but yeah there and
the access will be
built by this development to it as it
were
the that access road the access is drawn
going up to the site boundary in this
position here um
care home is anticipated to be in this
location here which is all within parcel
15 that was identified in the section
106 and the um development brief and
just can i have the assurances that
obviously it's moved from where it was
in the master plan
that presumably it could move again as
it were it could be
but that it won't get won't get lost as
it were and then i've got a second
question on landscaping please um well
we haven't got an application for the
care home but it was proposed to be
within this parcel 15 overall which is
where that remaining site could
accommodate it thanks and just while
you've got that slide up on the
landscaping on the um
the north side of the development which
on there is the right hand side um i
don't suppose you it's very difficult to
see the landscaping online um
but
do you have an indication of the width
as it works it it looks a bit inadequate
but if you know whether that's hedging
in trees and how deep that is there
because that'll be the edge of the site
thanks
it would i haven't got a specific um
width of the planting shown but it is
hedging it is hedging and trees native
hedging and trees
and the specification does talk about
the double staggered um lines for the
hedging
thanks casamayor
thank you um
the roads leading to the site
it's really quite complicated when
you've got a commercial operation i.e
the care home
and access to the houses
will the spine roads be adopted
they don't appear to be an adoptable
standard at the moment
uh the intention is that the roads would
be to adoptable standard and the outline
was for 15 dwellings and the care home
to be served off langton grove
as was mentioned previously there's no
direct vehicular
route through to the rest of the site
it's only the care home and 15 houses to
be served off langtong grove thank you
casterfield
thank you just to return the care home
there is sufficient area for
such a a building is there of course
somewhat concerned it seemed to have
shrunk a bit
and the second question will be about
the solar panels they seem to be sort of
tokens there's
three or four you know
a couple hundred quids with on on each
building and some of them are on
uh garages
which are lower and will be shielded by
the adjacent house
you don't get too much power out if you
should if you hide the sunlight so could
you
the care home is important is there any
area that solar panels are you assuring
us that it will be developed into a
sensible
system
well we haven't got any detail at all of
the care home and so we're
slightly operating um
as as a sort of envisaged but i've
spoken to highways and they they were
happy in terms of the likely accessing
and
parking provision
it would be limited it could it could be
a two-story uh in height
um
and that area of land um
would seem to be of a sufficient size um
we haven't got we haven't got the design
before us so we don't know exactly what
the floor plan of that
would be but there's there's probably
one and a half two acres or so there
a hectare sorry um
to accommodate the site
and i would anticipate that that would
be sufficient
um the solar panels yes they are shown
they're shown on each property um but
the detail of them
would be subject to that condition on
the outline that requires an energy
strategy to be submitted so it might end
up
a little bit different than is is
indicated at the moment
council amounts
uh thank you chair um um one of my
questions has already been answered um
but my other question relates to
the pedestrian access to the wider
the wider
outline permission and the existing
public right-of-way network
there is no direct link from this
application site to the existing public
right-of-way network which sort of
just touches the corner of the sort of
derelict building area
and the other thing i wanted to ask you
about on the wider
um
area of the outline permission there's a
sort of um bit sort of to the north west
of this plot which looks like it's
completely cut off
from the rest of the site but it was on
the existing outline
that um
you wouldn't be able to access
um should this go ahead so was that part
of the
drainage area or um something i'm not
quite sure what the future of that
particular sort of dog leg of red line
on the outline is now going to be cut
off
maybe you could just explain what that
bit of land is for thank you
thank you yes there isn't um
the footpath network doesn't quite come
up to the site um so but in due course
there would be linkages through again
reliant on the the second phase of
development um but the road and footpath
is shown to go right up to the site
boundary and there is that potential
cycle and pedestrian link from the south
west of the site again going into the
adjacent site
could we have the
yeah
so i think the buildings you're talking
about if i
it's not things it's the red if you look
at the red line on the site location
plan which is on 300 and page 302 shows
a sort of
bent bit of red line on the on the
outline permission that is completely
cut off by this application
yeah it'll take me a while to get to get
back there but it's um it's a potential
relocation of the farm buildings
presumably that would be served
uh from the adjacent farmland um
it's it was shown on the outline as the
relocation of the adjacent farm
buildings so that would come forward as
a as another application
and the access would be through the
road that goes to the care home is that
how it would be accessed
um i sub well i it's that's outside the
current application site it was part of
the outline
um
there isn't provision in this um
application for access to that site
whether it would come from other other
farmland which again surrounds the whole
of the parcel of land um
the landowner presumably um
would wish to retain some however an
access to his to his own land and his
farm buildings
thank you
okay uh councilman
thank you um yeah i was wondering
whether there are any um
any verbal updates or anything on the um
there's
various things i flagged up on page 182
183
case office and notes and and um
so on um
that um
where the these are the the bringing
forward of the
how the conditions are being met on the
outline
um now we understand that the conditions
on the outline prevail
um i think that what's kind of
unsatisfactory to somebody is that we
haven't got
much of that in front of us at the
moment if you remember in the previous
one we'd actually got as a late paper
the the sustainability condition how
that was to be met
um
and uh you know i think it makes up the
general point i think mr isabelle's got
now
from the committee that that we um you
know more of these conditions need to be
prior to or concurrent with reserve
matters
um rather than hanging over
beyond
beyond the reserve matters which is you
know i find uncomfortable
uh you know in terms of assessing what
we look in front that's at the moment so
if there's any any help you've got on
any of those
we've got surface water drainage highway
drawings electric vehicle
charging points
visibility displays we looked at those i
didn't quite understand
um
was addressing some perhaps some
objection
regarding the the visibility display and
and then the sustainability one
uh further down page 183 so there's a
few
a few different things there that um
you know i wondered if we've got any
more
any more knowledge about than when you
wrote the report
no there's nothing to update chairman um
but just that there are
details which would be required by the
conditions on the outline and the
visibility displays were are required by
the outline so they would need to be
provided
um
and
the final details of the surface water
drainage again is is a condition of the
outline although
the flood authority are happy with with
the layout it's some of the finer detail
that they now just want to sort out
on the the visibility display one year i
was a bit puzzled by
what why it was being stated the red
line
on the outline cannot be changed at this
stage um yeah i understand the words but
i just didn't understand why they were
there
the full extent of the visibility
displays
were not included in the red line of the
application of the outline application
of the outline
and so we can't now change
the red line of the application site
although there was a condition it's
condition 33 of the outline that the
approved langton grove access
and it specifies a drawing number should
be laid out and constructed in its
entirety
and that includes the visibility display
um so highways
were raising the point that the
visibility display isn't included in the
red line but it is conditioned um and
we're stuck with the red line of the
outline
yes
okay well thank you very much i'm going
to move us on then to public speakers um
is there any more questions the first
one is richard berry from the parish
council so again over to you have three
minutes please
thank you very much chair um i town
councilman concerns with this
application uh are not really centered
on uh the design quality or the mix of
the properties we we consider this to be
good design and good architecture and i
have to say in view of the discussion
earlier this morning it was a pity that
that's not reflected over a wider area
of the outlying consent if i could put
it that way
the case officer in her presentation
though confirmed that there had been
some departure from the indicative
master plan in in the eye neighbourhood
plan i have to say that i was pleased to
see the attention that councillors gave
the i neighborhood plan
as a current document
it's natural that there should be some
deviation it's an indicative plan after
all but it is in in in the neighborhood
plan and remembered by most of the
community it's the most frequently
quoted diagram that comes back to me so
therefore the community would like to
see a revised one
showing the treatment of the boundaries
between the two sites
there is a green way to be protected
between the persimmon side and this site
and we'd also like to see an indicative
location of the care home
we'd also like an assurance that the
empty space in this application is not
to be used to push the boundaries of the
280 for the outline permission as we
consider businesses business and it may
be a possibility
um
but
the application possibly does show the
difference between if you like bespoke
design which which we have here and
standard house types
we are
supporting the architecture at least in
this application subject to the
addressing of a revised indicative
master plan which the council would like
to see
just to conclude by saying that both
these sites and particularly perhaps
this one have great design potential
they have good open space relatively low
density
by modern day standards
and we'd absolutely support any measures
that members can bring about preserving
the integrity of those open spaces and
their management thank you
thank you very much any questions at all
no okay thank you and philip do you
comment on the master plan
uh
well not especially chairman i mean the
master plan is is a snapshot in time um
and it forms the basis for the uh the
outline permission but it's indicative
so revising an indicative is only going
to get you another indicative which
i i appreciate that that question of
certainty is difficult we have more than
one owner
i think the opportunity to revise an
indicative within
um
this is probably a conversation that uh
the town council and myself could take
up uh with
uh persimmon uh as a wider activity but
ultimately
there's probably something about how the
two owners uh collaborate on this and
don't know there's necessarily a
collaboration agreement in relation to
the total site
so um
the value of revising an indicative plan
i think to me
only takes you so far with another
indicative
okay thank you for that
okay um no questions to the parish
council so we'll move on um
now as it happens we don't have an
objective we don't have a support we
don't have the agent
and the ward member has nothing further
to add to what was said on the previous
application so it's over to us to
discuss debate and come to a conclusion
counselor mansell oh sorry eben
um since nobody else has ever hesitating
i think the interesting thing with this
particular application
is that um
it was very clear in the outline as to
what was
being asked for here in terms of that
had to be detached homes and it had to
be because it's on the edge of the area
so i think
um
[Music]
and that has been followed through
um unlike necessarily in the in the
previous one
the
so as far as i can see it
it follows pretty much what has been
expected
um from the outline and what the what
the residents of i would be therefore
expecting
to see here
the the
you know as far as the design and the
layout and so on i think you know it's
it looks
you know again in line with what was it
what was expected my only kind of
comments really and i'd be interested
what others say i think
the
points about the green way so in terms
of the where the
when you go into the site
on the left where the um
i think the nursery car parking is going
to be in there's a bit of a pond but
that then leads through into the site is
how that we ensure that that is um kept
as is and then we'll follow through into
the into the rest of the site but also
the northern boundary i've still got a
concern in general about landscaping and
i think
that we really should be
um ensuring that the landscaping on that
northern boundary is is as um
as as definite as possible and has got a
good
wide
um
you know it's a spacious site in terms
of housing on it so it's got a good wide
um area of hedging and um trees and
again they are started in in advance
um
other than that chair i can't i haven't
got any further comments to add i've
been just to see what everyone else says
thank you thank you very much
councilman
thank you um
yeah i was interested that the um
both the
town council and mr isabel have
sort of conceded that the master plan
which is contained within the
neighborhood plan
is is only indicative
um
i i did quite wonder about that reading
what the town council had said about
these two applications really um
you know so how
how strong that master plan was as
policy and the answers well
yeah up to a point but not very much
kind of thing um and that's it sort of
leaves me wondering a little bit whether
whether neighborhood plans need to have
something i don't know is it a design
brief does that become more strong or
something i mean in terms of this
application right now um
it's um it's it's pretty pretty nearly
there really i i can't see any reasons i
wanted to object to it um it's just a
little more certainty about some of the
uh the conditions on the outline being
met properly and the
the the totality of the
outline being
satisfactory delivered that the council
of manchester was being picked up
already
so any help on that but um no particular
big issues okay thank you i just want to
go to philippismo on this point thank
you yeah just just to pick up on
that point about the status of the plan
i mean it is part of the development
plan it sits within eyes neighborhood
plan and that is how they expect to see
the development come forward the problem
is that on the outline permission it is
only it is indicative and
you know a little bit of give a little
bit of take here or there within the red
line totality of the site
will always happen with the reserve
matters application so
to that extent i mean i think it's
useful to revise the inform the the
indicative plan
but on the critical document which is
going to be the planning commission
that's the document everyone should turn
back to
and we'll still be looking back to that
you know and we'll be trying to read a
bunch of documents together i i's
neighbourhood plan is a company by its
own neighborhood master planning and
design guidance that's quite detailed um
that sets out principles for how you
should be going about the activity of of
designing these things but obviously
you know you've got you're trying to fit
two or three documents together and it's
not a neat clean fit but i accept
you know the the evolution of the master
plan is almost predictable on any site
and it's sensible to pick up here
yeah yeah thank you chair yeah i mean i
the you know i accept that
the you know moving the moving of the
the um the care home and so on yet yes
yes that's very
you know minor within et cetera it's
it's more this question of whether the
you know whether the bits join up
uh and um and that the overall scheme is
is getting delivered that is a worry
really
i mean it seems to me that persimmon
have
expressed their reservations
um
about the the the
cycle and
the pedestrian connection
because it's with another landowner but
this is the other land owner so they've
got their
they've got their end a bit marked up on
there as well so it looks as if that's
effectively secure isn't it is that
about the same one that persimmon were
talking about it's not a hard luck
casa plasma
thank you very much chairman um well i
actually rather like this application
and um
having heard what everybody else has
said i don't think it's particularly
controversial so i
again i am going to propose um
approval but there are a few conditions
to add and i think some of the concerns
the town counts have raised i take on
board um phillips condabet having a
dialogue so
i don't know if you can actually
condition that because again
there are things you could do to try and
ease some of the concerns there was one
i didn't write it down but there was
some concern about overlooking of some
houses on one of the boundaries um it's
in the papers but i didn't write it down
um but if that could be addressed it's
in one of the objections of the town
council
buffy close or something
um
that's my mistake for not writing it
down here we go i've got it
um yes it's on page 198.2
at the bottom there about um a loss of
amenity with rear windows and gardens
overlooking the new homes in both close
i'm sure that could be delegated to
address that without having to come back
to this committee if members approved
i'm really pleased to hear um the issues
about
permeability
solar panels air force heat pumps i
think the layout it's a could be a
really really spectacular development
there i do know the area really well
i say really well reasonably well not in
detail
but i do want to tighten up a little bit
on the landscaping the timing of
planting
again really good high quality
landscaping with decent trees not little
short ones there and of course including
our old friend on the biodiversity
things like um
swift cups even possibly in some cases
swallow boxes if the
open plan of some of the gouges or
whatever it does permit it but again i
think delegating that for the
biodiversity hedgehog
fences and so on that should all be done
and any decent developer would actually
should take them on course as a matter
of principle in the first place so we're
very keen on that in this committee and
um so therefore
with those couple of conditions about
the ecology stroke planting
and discussions with the town council to
try and address some of their concerns
i would propose formally approval
sean you want to come in yeah i just
wanted to uh address your point about
the um overlooking and the residence at
bother close um when the
um scheme first came forward there were
two story properties there and they were
nearer to the boundaries so now they're
single story and they're 18 meters away
from the boundary so
that's been addressed
councilman
i think i i would i would be
happy to second this actually i've got
um
on these conditions i noted on page
hundred and i said 84
um
that yeah there's a paragraph about the
pond
which seems to call for a condition
effectively and um and also then the
next paragraph about the landscape
consultants and so on you know i think
the discussions we've we've already had
um
apply there so that's that's the other
condition that mr barcelona council
possible passwords already
looking for and the other one i did
think we could given that there's a
number of bungalows
proposed that it would be entirely
reasonable to
um to accept the disability forum
suggestion of 50 percent
m42
um
compliance
with with in terms of um disabled access
that should be very easy to deliver with
all these bungalows thank you
okay so we've everyone anyone else wish
to speak yeah cancer manslaughter cancer
yeah well i just wanted to to check that
the uh condition regarding the
landscaping included councillor ebon's
comment about the
boundary on the northern side being
beefed up a bit or whatever being more
more prominent or better than it looks
in the picture
okay
yeah i think this is a good layout um
the um the solar panels on the roof i'll
agree with cancer field i did a quick
calculation you'd need 21
meter and square meters of solar panels
to run a heat pump
um but
solar panels on the roof is great it's
good to see um it will do something
towards the energy of that
the energy consumption the um
the only thing that i'll say about this
is is this a good opportunity to put
native apple trees in that where those
six
trees are in the middle of that um
that sort of um roundabout sort of bit
um i'd like to see that i can leave that
with the officers but i think that would
be a good addition to this but apart
from that i really like it
happy to vote for it thank you encounter
food you want to come in
just briefly i think i counted the solar
panels there's four on each house
that's
that's about 400 pounds worth on about a
three-quarter million pound house um if
i may be allowed that it clearly should
be increased from a token number and i
think i i hope that's part of the
agreement and
i've done about 21 meters that sounds
like a quite a high number but one would
also recommend that they're put in
places where they're not she shielded by
the rest of the house but without to
comment on so quite happy with this
thank you so can i ask you just to run
through uh all the additional points
just to make sure we're clear there's
been proposed by council passed one
second about council matheson
thank you jeremy i do need to clarify
quite what council password was
expecting in relation to the town
council points so
it's not typically the territory of a
condition i'm just wondering if the
concern here is about linking these
items together that
um there is a point of a condition which
requires a revision of that master plan
as part of this and probably i'll tell
you that back in relation to the other
application which is already a delegated
item so i've got discretion to add a
condition there but to
to ensure that there is that revision so
that we have the sites delivering the
pieces of this jigsaw
that we anticipate i mean you've got in
the recommended conditions
a a a you know details pedestrian
cycling and obviously that question of
development and phasing ties in with
that
so chairman ol
i'll add a condition
to
require the
agreement of a revision of the master
plan
for this parcel
uh in relation to
uh the future development of the um
care home and arrangements there and
[Music]
the other point i have
much as with the earlier application i'm
suggesting that we have a scheme of
landscape and ecological mitigation and
enhancement
time taking we have the landscaping
details as with the other application
but it is effectively becomes back to
requiring planting of the boundaries of
the site and odd day
a lot later than commencement so that
was one condition which i think
effectively is largely as before
and then on plot enhancements and
picking up
the points from place services on page
184
clearly there's swift nest boxes um
martin the cups hedgehog permeable
boundaries and i've noticed aquatic
enhancements now
there is a condition on the outline
which relates to a series of ecological
mitigation steps
if you're happy i'll add ecological
aquatic enhancements to the condition
that you authorize but it may well be
they're already addressed in that
but it does no harm to include them
thank you
and m42 50 percent
i must have missed that during debate
chairman perhaps you can remind me what
councilman
as laid out from page 184 it's presumed
the bungalow's
50 will be m42 adaptable and accessible
standards
[Music]
okay so on that basis we're going to go
to a vote please
thank you chair members that vote should
now be in progress in your app
council field
thank you
councillor carsten are you okay to vote
thank you members that's eight votes for
chair that's carried okay thank you very
much that's unanimous okay so what i
propose doing now is to take a break
come back at 1 15 and then at 1 15 we'll
run through the final two applications
without a break if we don't break now
there's no chance of getting any lunch
in any of the facilities but downstairs
is open to 130 as is over the road okay
so we'll meet back here at 115 sharp
please thank you
okay everyone so welcome back uh so
we're gonna move on to the next
application before us which is um
the number is dc2103292
this is a planning application in south
of birch avenue in backton
um and phillips just going to just say
something before we go to the case
officer so phillip
uh thank you chairman apologies for the
confusion that i might cause by saying
this you have a recommendation in your
papers which effectively is split into
two parts
um
and and we are actually going to put a
separate single recommendation to you to
clear
the two points so
um vince will talk to this as we go
through but i think
with reflection putting it in the option
one and option two thing perhaps is more
confusing than it needs to be i'm sure
members are absolutely on top of those
two recommendations but for
entertainment we are going to
uh recommend
the the that you ignore those and that
we have a single consolidated
recommendation which mr vincent will now
definitely move along to to describe
effectively this is just to do with how
we deal with the question of the rail
crossing point so if i can hand over to
vince now
all should become clear the bulk of the
conditions there's no change to those
it's just
that
thank you philip good afternoon cheer
members ladies and gentlemen
let us proceed
in terms of
where we were last time you saw this
back on 29th of november last year when
you instructed the chief planning
officer to have further discussion with
network rail over the question of the
crossing you were happy in principle
with the development and you indicated
that
if philip could resolve the issue with
network rail you would want to grant
planning permission subject to a section
106 so as phil says we are simply
looking at the question of the railway
crossing
on the screen is the
amended recommendation i will come to
that at the end but just that's there
just to reaffirm
the point made by philip that there is
an amended recommendation
so we have discussed the situation with
network rail
they support the principle of the
development
but they have concerns at potential
increased risk
through the additional use of the
crossing and we'll explore that a little
later as we go through this presentation
network rail have suggested they have a
hierarchy of preferences for the
crossing so
top of the list is extinguish the
railway crossing and divert
users mostly pedestrian cyclists to the
public paths
this is of course the route of a public
right-of-way designated public
right-of-way footpath number 13
suffolk county council have already said
that they oppose the
closure of that footpath and
they object to the
extinguishment
of the crossing
next on the list for network rail is to
extinguish the existing crossing and
divert users to what would be a new
stepped bridge
third on the list is
a bridge but with a ramp
or a subway under the railway and then
fourth
is a system of lights and warnings
and gates
so that pedestrians and cyclists wishing
to cross have adequate warning that
there is a train
coming
as i say suffolk county council oppose
closure of the public right-of-way and
they have opposed the transport works
order to extinguish the crossing
just to familiarize everyone with where
beckton
is
north of stone market between the a140
and the a14
not that far from elmswell
so here we have the application site
that you've seen the yellow
was the railway
and on this slide you see the layout
that you previously were minded to grant
permission for and the dashed purple
line is the line of the public
right-of-way and the crossing point over
the railway
so obviously the trains are going up and
down and you'll see the footpath
flashing
you may say well why are people wanting
to cross at that point what is the
attraction of of getting to the other
side of the
railway track most of the facilities as
you can see
already on the west side of that railway
line
well the answer is that
there are sports facilities on the other
side of the railway so we've got backton
united 89 the football club
and that route is used
in order to get to and from the sports
facilities from the majority of the
village
as you can see you can go through the
site and end up in broad road should you
wish to
cut right across the field now the
advantage is of course that that
crossing shortens your journey
um
significantly
so to get
from the development to the
football club building would be 200
meters using the crossing if you had to
walk around the
existing roads that would be a kilometer
a five times longer
walk and so the county council are
insistent that there is actually a very
strong
need for that crossing they opposed the
extinguishment
of the crossing on the basis that there
is no suitable alternative route for
pedestrians
if we can quickly if this works quickly
fly so here we have birch avenue running
top to bottom on the left of the screen
you can just see the line
this works
yes
just here you can see where people walk
across and there's the crossing
so we quickly fly around and you can see
it's a relatively short walk before
you're certainly at the football pitches
and the clubhouse
the alternative
you start at the same
same point you have to go up birch
avenue
then you go along plough hill under the
railway bridge
right the way along to broad road turn
right
work your way right along broad road
until you get to the sports facilities
at that point
just to emphasize the preferences from
network rail closure bridge underpass
and then some sort of warning barrier
what belway the developer are proposing
is a warning system with gates and other
alarms
to provide
advanced warning of trains coming so on
this simple diagram taking up the yellow
dot in the field just before you get to
the
existing crossing there will be a gate
a system of fences
and alarms we've got some elevations so
the photograph on the
top right illustrates the type of
warnings
that will be available
and what i'm suggesting through the
chief planning officer is that we get
additional detail if you're minded to
agree the recommendation just to ensure
we understand whether there are
collections whether it's flashing lights
as well is there a cctv
exact position of those gates is it one
side or
two sides
again cross sections across the railway
obviously you could walk round that
but you can at the moment this is an
existing public right-of-way that is
well used
so what do you see at the moment so you
walk
across the field in the middle distance
you can see some of the
signage you
you
use a style
and then you walk up a slight gradient
and then you're across the railway
at the moment there isn't any warning
whatsoever
you only have your eyes to make sure
that there's nothing
coming it is a straight section of
of track but
trains could be moving at 100 miles an
hour along this section of the
of the railway
so what is it that we are proposing
effectively we are suggesting that the
recommendation that you saw back in
november in terms of the development
itself remains unchanged
but we are going to suggest that within
the section 106 agreement there is an
additional clause
that requires
an appropriate railway crossing
mitigation scheme to be agreed with the
council and a timetable for its
delivery
our view is that having a system that
had gates alarms
is safer than the existing situation the
committee is
minded to support the development this
would provide users of that
path a safer way of crossing to get to
and from
the sports ground
the conditions that we're suggesting are
as previously
proposed so as philip says our
recommendation to you is that we now
require
the section 106 agreement to be expanded
to agree the securing of that
crossing
system mitigation system
and at that point the development can
proceed
phillip
uh
chem
so what you have is a recommendation for
an obligation to require the agreement
of a scheme
um there is a and it doesn't alter the
meat and drink of what you have on page
five two one five two two of your papers
from network rail which was
uh
uh there
it starts on 5 19. 195
18 it's it's there simply the january
letter um as ever our friends at network
rail sent us something yesterday which
which we picked up during the course of
the morning and uh i've just been
skimming that as mr vincent has been
talking effectively we have no change to
the position
albeit i think uh as part of
construction mitigation network rail are
now also looking to
seek some
additional gatagen fencing in relation
to the western side of the footpath as
it approaches the railway
and from my perspective all of that is
within the scope of a scheme
and i think that a scheme is a broad
enough set of words to enable us to
try and reach a conclusion about the
appropriate way of dealing with the risk
here chairman
and
so i'm not going to summarize the rest
of networks for our network rails
fairly lengthy position their
recommendations
remain effectively to seek the
[Music]
extinguishment of the public right away
and include amongst other things stop
lights
but they seem to have added some
comments about working with ourselves
with the county council rights away team
to uh manage uh access from the western
side and i think that's sensible but i
think this needs further work which
doesn't necessarily um affect the
recommendation we're putting to you
today
thank you chairman
thank you um i just
so in terms of um
well let's take questions first yeah
council matters and then cancer field
yeah i always disappeared now but i i
saw the word timetable was there
um i think that
based on experience
of network rail and so on um we need
ways and words of naming that down very
firmly so it actually gets delivered in
a timely way
um
alongside the development or before or
something but um definitely
that is a
really apart from that that's the only
concern
just into questions at the moment
okay
okay
so chairman network braille's preference
is that the mitigations be completed
prior to occupation
um so i think there's a co so i think
there's a conversation about what timing
this would actually involve to get
whatever process is in place and they've
got choices highways stopping up or
extinguishment procedures they're a
separate matter you know that runs
separate to the playing issue i think
the point is
at what point does the risk of users
using this crossing
increase materially such that it would
be a source of concern
so so chairman the expectation under
this condition and there will inevitably
need to be some negotiation is that this
sorry this obligation uh is something
which is timed against the delivery of
the development
so that this is a sequence of steps
to mitigate relative to occupation
thank you cassify
yes just a couple of questions the um
thinking of one's experience at gypsy
loan in neither market the uh
i thought that the
number of systems that british rail are
able to install is limited by the
railing spectra
and that um
there are a few of them so i was
wondering if the proposal you're
making there is a known approved scheme
that the railways can
deploy because clearly the
their option d in storm miniature stop
lights although they seem ridiculously
expensive as stop lights but
nevertheless is an approved
scheme that they can use and i'm not
quite sure
where we're deviating and as long as
we're deviating to good purpose but
knowing the
a railing spectra are difficult people
so um i'm i think i don't know if you
can answer i noticed the applicants are
nodding so i'm guessing it has been so
we can ask them when we come to your
point um but phillip do you want to add
anything uh very simply chairman the
suite of recommendations a to d are the
shopping list that i would be expecting
to choose from but not some other thing
that has no track record they are
options and choices that network rail
have set out as being
their preferences that is i think what
the scheme would need to be okay well
that's clearly thank you
councilman
uh sorry to harp on about the um
the timing of the mitigation
it's all very well having a clause
that the it has to be done at a certain
time in the development but if network
rail have got anything to do with it
how are we ever going to insist that
they do it
within the time constraints that is in
the section 106 agreement because we all
know other places in the district where
that clearly has not happened
thank german um yes
so we do all know other places where
network rail have
covered themselves in timetabling glory
um
from my point of view you've got a
series of options there and if those
options cannot be delivered in a
realistic timetable the option d in
store miniature lights is there is
credible appears to be something that is
likely to be approvable on the rail
network and seems to be
subject to question of cost
a matter that could be delivered
relative to occupations and the point is
at what point the risk
the risk profile changes when you is it
one person living in one house
is it two people is it three people you
know you have a foot crossing which you
know there is a risk there already from
people accessing the football uh
facilities going across to and from the
village
so at what point does that change from
one categorization to another would be
my way of judging this
and
um
if if these if if a to c are not
deliverable in a reasonable time scale
it is likely to from my perspective that
d is
subject to whatever the cost question is
i mean i don't know what else i can say
chairman from a planning perspective
they are choices that network rails say
are acceptable choices
and from a planning perspective you have
a means to deliver a decision
and a resolution
well we can't we'll come to that maybe
i'll catch you later about the other one
okay any more questions yes counselor
eben
um just a quick one chair for the
for the avoidance of doubt we're looking
at the
set of lights and and so on and this is
that what we
is being recommended here is to put some
mitigation in about
what they call it install miniature stop
lights and just to
add
i don't think
well possibly won't be able to answer
this be nice to have network rail here
but
lots of young people use that because
opposite the
development there's this the estate that
this development is on the edge of it's
got a lot of families and across the
road from that's got a lot of families
and they use that to get to the
football pitches um which are very
active football club with a lot of young
people playing there so just in terms of
obviously currently they cross that
without any
gates well just with a rackety or gate
but
in terms of safety this obviously would
be an improvement
so the answer to that question chairman
is i think in reality it is likely that
the miniature stoplight option d is most
likely to be one delivered but in
fairness to network rail they have set
other
other objectives there i think it will
be
churlish of officers to say they're off
the table although in reality i think
the lights will become
the way of managing this
and the earlier we can deliver this the
the greater improvement that there is
for uh existing users of the footway
um
the the the dealing with network rail
feasibility studying all these things
are things to be
worked through and i'm fully sure that
council manson will want a fairly long
conversation with me after this and i
look forward to it
okay uh anyone else have any questions
at this point
no okay thank you um so we're moving on
um we don't have
anyone from the parish council we don't
have an objective supporter we do have
the agent so seth patel
over to you
good afternoon members
i speak on behalf of my client beltware
homes eastern counties we support the
case officers recommendations
since november's 21 2021 committee we
have worked closely with the case
officer network rail to try and agree
the removal of their holding objection
the holding objection is based upon the
assumed increased safety risk of the
level crossing that would allegedly be
caused by our housing development
however it's important to understand
that the existing crossing is currently
open to all users
including those in burch avenue and
prittman avenue with only a style to
navigate
there is also no safety fence or gate to
discourage the discourage the perceived
misuse of the level crossing by networ
rail
as as already mentioned network have
tried to close the level crossing
through the twao process in november
2020 and the secretary of state refused
that closure due to no suitable
alternative being available
nevertheless
as mentioned we have extensively engaged
continue to engage with network rail on
trying to find a suitable mitigation
strategy that is both reasonable and
proportionate to the scale of
development
however our proposal to install a safety
gate and fence
within our site
would enhance the safety of the existing
crossing but was not considered a
sufficient uh measure by network rail
however it is supported
in principle by the case officer the
public rights wave manager and having
spoken to councillors mellon and
stringer who we've also been engaging
with since november
it became apparent during discussions
with network they were looking to use
our application to facilitate the
closure of the level crossing that they
had failed to achieve in 2020
in addition
none of the four recommendations that
were made by network rail were
considered acceptable
as none of them would meet the stills
test of having to be necessary to make
the development acceptable related to
the development and fair and reasonable
to the scale of development
networks holding objection is based upon
an assumed risk assumed safety risk of
the level crossing caused by development
however
when when asked about the assumptions
that network rail have used to justify
their position they have confirmed that
in their view this development
itself would result in 170 two-way
movements across that railway line every
day
that's effectively the number of houses
times two
having spoken to local councillors
melanie stringer about this and their
experience of the level crossing they
consider that level of movement to be
significant significant overestimation
and completely unrealistic
it's become clear that network rail also
have not factored in the alternative
routes and play provisions that are
being provided as part of our housing
scheme
and the fact that all essential services
are located on the western side of um
backton
it was also confirmed at our last
meeting last thursday with network rail
that a bridge in the location of the
level crossing would not be
suitable therefore we believe the most
suitable and reasonable form of
mitigation to overcome network rail
safety concerns is to have a safety gate
and fence along the boundaries of our
site
with the level crossing
as i say we have engaged extensively
with key stakeholders and network rail
to try and overcome their objections
even in light of the extant outline
permission for which a mitigation
strategy would not be required
we therefore hope committee agrees to
the recommendations made and approves
the application so that beltway can
install a safe mitigation measure and
deliver much needed housing
thank you
i did sorry i you've gone over by about
10 seconds i think we're there thank you
very much um okay so thank you for that
uh we've got a few questions yep we'll
start off with council even councilor
manson
um thank you chair just a
quick one which i think actually is
probably more for the planning officer
so if we um agree a recommendation of a
scheme
then presumably that is between then the
planning officer the applicant and
network rail to agree whatever whether
that includes
lights rails well shouldn't say rails
fences sorry gates or whatever so it's
it is a scheme that is the
point picks up clearly
sorry yes chairman you have options on
the table that network rail have put
forward there may yet be other options
not yet described it is we would expect
a scheme to to be demonstrated by
somebody qualified to demonstrate such
matters that this will not increase risk
for future occupants so that effectively
at
at worst the risk profile does not
worsen
um thank you chair um did i hear you um
say that bellway homes would be
constructing a fence and a gate on on
the western side of the railway line
crossing regardless of whatever
mitigation
uh network rail decide to put on their
bit of land
the the the safety gate and fence is a
mitigation measure the network that
bellway have proposed to put together to
overcome networls objection and they
feel that that is the most proportionate
and reasonable form of mitigation um
we've we we have although networl have
in their fourth recommendation
considered the the possibility of
a signalized gating facility um the cost
of that is 1.4 million pounds which
would be a significant which would which
would be completely unreasonable for
beltway to to provide hence why we think
a gate
an offence would be more more of a
proportionate response to installing
some form of mitigation
and what about the bit on the other side
which isn't your land you're saying that
you're only going to put a gate on the
western side so people coming from the
east
there will be no mitigation whatsoever
so when they come back from the football
club
the mitigation's gone
essentially the safety of the railway
cross railway line is the responsibility
of network rail um we can only do what
we can do within our red line boundary
and uh so um if network feel that it is
necessary to install some form
mitigation on that side of the fence and
that is that is for them to that is for
him
click on that maybe this is a question
for the planning officers but but um i
thought this was part of the section 106
agreement so if network rail do decide
that there is to be a um a light
crossing
whatever whatever it's called signal
controlled thing with lights on it
um
does that not mean that's got to come
out of section 106 funds
and therefore it beltway will be having
to give network rail some money to do to
do it
chairman if this is a condition or an
obligation it's got to be paid for by
somebody it's got to be to a standard
which ensures that people's safety is
reasonably mitigated we as planners are
not rail engineers we need advice from
somebody competent to advise on that
the the resolution of the harm is to
mitigate the risk in using the crossing
and so
the cost of it is not actually
material for the purposes of this
conversation so it could be
a condition i believe it's tighter and
more secure and more effective as an
obligation but we would as planners as
the planning authority consult with
network rail upon receipt of a scheme
and what i would expect is that bellway
take advice in order to prepare that
scheme so that that scheme can then be
signed off and agreed but if you if you
leave it hostage to
sign off by network rail it will be to
whatever network i want so it is not
their call it is the planning
authorities and i think as a as an
obligation it indicates its importance
and is not um
does not get lightly set aside
i just i don't know phillip you might
shoot me down in flames but clearly well
it seems to me belway don't own the land
on the other side but what if the club
were receptive to the idea of
a similar sort of arrangement being
built on their land
i could imagine a situation where the
scheme that philip is considering
includes a gate on the other side very
similar to the gate on the west side it
would just require the club to be
willing participants
in that process
but if network rail don't agree to just
having a gate
does that put the whole
development in jeopardy because if they
decide that that isn't sufficient
mitigation
and no one's got any money to pay the
1.5 million for the lights
and therefore
what happens to the development if if it
can't be done
so uh drawing on other experience in the
district as one does
um
it is not easy dealing with network rail
and we know that from from other sites
and
i think from our perspective at the
moment we believe on balance it is an
on-balance test that there is a
potential for a scheme to be
delivered which can be
uh agreed with network well they they
they object but they set out options
and those options uh you know can be
pursued it might be that you uh look at
one and then and then choose another i
mean these things are all there and
network rail are not the sole arbiters
of advice we take advice from the home
authority and without being rude to the
highway authority from time to time we
also take advice from highway engineers
who are independent of the highway
authority and we perfectly well accept
that so uh network are not the only
persons capable of advising on this and
obviously they have an objective to
achieve there needs to be a scheme and
i think this can this is complicating a
planning decision
which is not a network safety decision
what you need as a committee is to be
comfortable that future occupiers and
it's not users of the football these
future occupiers who might use this
crossing are not exposed to
increased unacceptable risk and that to
my mind is the planning test here so it
may ask through you chair philip in
response to
council of mensah's question what would
happen
if having considered the range of
options in a scheme you felt that there
wasn't a scheme that you could approve
what happens then
if chairman if there's a range so that
interesting to be asked question by the
officer
thank you
um so so um
if there is not a scheme that can be
approved then uh clearly one would have
to look at the reasonableness of the um
requirement
but that's what unlocks your granting a
planning commission and it is an
obstacle to the delivery of the site a
section 106 runs for five years and
can't be challenged in that time
planning permission lasts for three
years you know clearly you have time on
your side for the parties to get
together and to sort out what mitigation
is appropriate here
so from my point of view if
if the ski if there is not a deliverable
scheme then the planning commission
will not be deliverable the homes will
not be built because you
you you
you should not be taking a decision
which increases risk i mean this is safe
and suitable access for all people it's
that territory that we're in
but i think the point is we we do not
have a conclusion around what is the
right mitigation
and at what point that engages i'm not
sure if that goes anywhere close to
answering either your question or get
some answers
councilman you want to come in
thanks
the crossing we've got to mitigate the
risk
but the agent used the words
fair and reasonable to the scale of
development
are you
putting on the spot but are you happy
that 1.2 million pounds is fair and
reasonable
we'll miss the point
so i haven't been talking in terms of
money i've been talking in terms of a
scheme of mitigation
i've i've seen various people quote
various things about price and there's
talk of a feasibility study and we've
had
network rail and funding feasibility
studies in relation to thurston station
and we've done this elsewhere
i i think what this does is it unlocks
the opportunity for the parties to get
together and to sort out the actual true
cost and the true
consequence of what mitigation is
involved what is the light design what
is required in terms of consensus and
arrangement to work on the network to
get
lined up wiring or whatever either side
1.2 million i'm
i don't
you know from my perspective there is
sufficient here on balance to consider
it a reasonable solution
and if it is not deliverable as a
reasonable solution to mitigate the harm
arising from this development then it
will not be possible to discharge the
obligation
and it is on the burden is on the
applicant to demonstrate that they can
satisfy that the test
as a planning authority we should we
should not be putting people at greater
risk at greater harm
and my expectation much with a scheme to
agree a driveway we should not expect
a a an implica a consequence which
increases materially
risk inevitably some risk can happen at
some times
any access you could get knocked over on
so the way the planning system is geared
is around you know in terms of vehicle
access
you know substantive harm and from my
perspective the cost of it
will depend on what detail is sorted out
there are choices here which have
different costings
and they are
for the developer to explore and for the
developer to put the evidence to us that
there is a satisfactory scheme that can
be delivered this is somebody else's
regulation it's a public right-of-way
what we don't want is people from the
houses
being knocked down on the railway line
that's our objective and the planning
purpose of the obligation is to obscure
that to secure that objective at the
moment i don't believe that's unviable
and i believe that's a reasonable
objective to pursue through a planning
obligation
thank you
okay don't forget we are on questions to
the applicant still but it can be other
questions as well uh council field and
council matters
i'll really return to my earlier
question i i say having had some
experience standing in for the county
councillor
involved in the gypsy lane crossing this
area where as you well aware someone was
killed on the crossing
and knowing the mayhem that that
generated i just wanted to be sure that
the the route that
um phil is suggesting sounds very
sensible and the costs that british rail
are quoting seemed high
but
we have to understand that british rail
is controlled by i think it says here
her majesty's inspectorate of railways
it's not purely their
viewers what is safe and what is not
there is an independent inspectorate
which is an element of the government
involved in those decisions i wanted to
be sure that what belway are offering
is in accordance with things that are
currently acceptable on the railway
and speaking from past experience again
it didn't look anything like the system
that was proposed in the other location
i've seen so just try and establish that
before we move forward with a a sensible
approach
sorry yes um
so just going back on um a couple of
those points um that that fourth
recommendation for the uh signalized um
lighting um proposal um
you know network said that they have
costed that uh
and that will come out to be 1.4 million
pounds hence why we think
it is disproportionate to
it to
for belway to bring that forward um as a
form of litigation now belway are
willing to bring some form of mitigation
forward um in in the form of a of a gate
a a a safety gate an offence which
currently obviously isn't there at the
moment
um and and so what i would want to avoid
is tying down the mitigation strategy to
a particular type of mitigation strategy
because clearly network rail have set
out what they would want to see
as as part of that mitigation strategy
and the costs of that mitigation
strategy in terms of what that would be
um in terms of what would happen if
obviously um
you know
this this game didn't go forward
there is an outline consent already
extent on this site which obviously the
principle of development's been
established for that and fellway if we
couldn't get an agreement or the
condition is such or the obligation is
such that it is unreasonable that they
can't facilitate uh the approval
process with network rail and the
council and i'm glad to hear that um
from phil that that decision-making
process lies with the council not with
network rail um it ne elway would be
forced or would have to consider uh
submitting a reserve matters application
for that outline consent for which uh
you know
the public uh local res uh the parish
council global councillors have
don't think is it is suitable because
the scheme that we've put together
working closely with
them is a much better scheme
for them as a community
so i just wanted to just make sure that
um any um
any recommendation of an obligation or
condition whatever the process is that
it doesn't tie down beltway to a certain
requirement
that network rail need to
require as part of their uh servicing
for that or the safety of the crossing
thank you councilman
thank you yeah what seemed like a long
time ago now i was going to ask mr patel
and bellway
your proposal for for a gate etc that
you put to them to the network rail um
did that include um
linkage to their signaling system such
that it would it would flash and and and
so forth um when the train was coming
the mitigation strategy we put forward
was a sort of an in principle it hasn't
been proper it hasn't detailed up
because that was part of the negotiation
with network rail that we were having
and hoping to try and find some common
ground on and we're hoping that part of
this if it is a condition or an
obligation to for the mitigation
strategy we can agree those try trying
to agree those details through that
process
um
if that answers your question okay
not not really chair that the you know
these
the standard issue that we're talking
about here of a
klaxon and license and crossings and so
on um is connected to the signaling
system it therefore tells you that a
train is coming
so surely you've
you know you've either
said to network rail
we would like to link our gate to your
system or or that they've said you can't
or something
um you know
you know if you've had lots of
discussions with them you must have
explored that point i would think
[Music]
so i think that was part of that 1.4
million pound uh recommendation for the
um signalized um
crossing point that they were proposing
does it all form part of that process
which obviously we don't
belwe aren't going to be what you're
delivering because that is too
disproportionate
okay
well thank you for that okay so we'll
move on um
okay so we move on to the ward member so
a board member can't be here today so
i'm going to read this out so i'm not
here's from councillor andy mellen i'm
unable to attend today but i hope that
the following notes will help the
committee with its decision
committee members will be aware that
this application became before you
already last year
although on behalf of the community i
opposed the original outline application
once the principle of development was
agreed the parish council council
stringer myself have worked with bellway
to amend and approve the development and
this was reflected in the reserve
matters application which i supported
last time and continued to support today
the only outstanding issue is the
pedestrian railway crossing which takes
the footpath from this site over the
line to backton football club
network rail have long held a desire to
close this crossing however in recent
rounds of closures whilst other
crossings nearby were closed
this one was kept open due to there
being no viable alternative routes for
pedestrians it is not a heavily used
crossing but it is an important one for
a few people who use it and i support
the county rights of way officers in
wanting to keep it open
whilst the development on this site
could mean a slight increase in foot
traffic
most of the services in the village are
in the opposite direction the school the
shop the pub and the doctor surgery all
to the west and that is the direction
most pedestrians will go
network rail has speculated that the
number of people using the crossing will
go up by 170 a day but i can see no
evidence for this figure and i believe
the number of users will be much lower
the possible mitigation suggested
closure of the crossing is unacceptable
neither a bridge nor a tunnel are
suitable and the gate and lights
proposed an estimated cost of 1.4
million seems unreasonable
belway have shown me their own scheme of
mitigation on this side of the track
which i believe reasonably addresses the
safety concerns
i think if this is conditioned option
two in the recommendation that members
can confidently approve these reserve
matters
that's from councillor andy mellon
okay so can i just ask because obviously
councilman has taken us back to point so
can we just have uh phil could you just
take us absolutely through the
recommendations again just so we're
absolutely clear what we're looking at
before we get into debate
and certainly chairman two seconds
so
the recommendation you now have
i can just find it chairman
which screen chairman yes
so
so effectively the recommendation that
you'll see within your system we'll see
that we'll basically say that authority
be delegated to the chief planning
officer that subject to the prior
agreement of a section 106 planning
obligation on appropriate terms
to the satisfaction the chief planning
officer has summarized below and with
other obligations as may be deemed
necessary by him to secure affordable
housing on-site open space as detailed
community centre and education an
appropriate railway crossing mitigation
scheme and timetable for its delivery
two things one we are not looking to
prescribe or exclude options for what a
scheme might eventually prove to be
at the moment network rail have set down
options they prefer you've heard from
gentlemen from bellway from our
perspective there is reasonable
opportunity to consider a scheme and to
prescribe it in these words would would
would con would constrain
the ability to negotiate what that might
prove to be in an acceptable format and
the timetable for its delivery then
bears upon occupation because the risk
is something that will arise as
occupations take place
there will inevitably be some minor risk
associated with people who are building
the buildings
but the real
the real
harm stroke risk issue for you as a
committee arises as a proportion of the
number of users grow and use that
crossing and
you've heard that the uh assumptions by
network rail have been challenged
from my perspective this is the
territory of professional advice and
resolving that with network rather than
in terms of cost you can see that the
options that network have set out
include various various cost choices
they say lighting would cost 1.4 million
the last time i dealt with gypsy lane
situation in need of market i think
bridge cost about 1.1 million so i'm
quite not quite sure what the difference
is between that and lights but i'm not
network rail they will need a
feasibility study there will be these
things to do but that's the authority
chairman and the conditions follow along
and it is simply that last bullet that
is
in essence the distillation of what's
previously in your papers
into something
which
we expect
the applicant to go away and do homework
about
council manson will know what's happened
in relation to hawken lane in elmswell
and the challenges of that
i'm not underestimating the challenge of
dealing with network rail but we do have
a planning permission
that we granted uh the 55 14 18 of 18
application
um and i'm i'm just checking as to the
situation in relation to our
consultation with network rail there
because i can imagine the network rail
would have been consulted at that time
and should have consult commented
and i will just tell you uh
moment i'm waiting for my officers to
revoke so if i can come back to you on
that one chairman okay well i think
that's clear what we're being asked to
decide today so councilman you want to
kick off the debate
well it's really a question but happy to
start the debate um
is there any way we can just strengthen
that
um
sentence
to include
protection in both directions
i do
councillor mansell made the point that
what beltway are putting on the table is
a gate on one side
chairman yes you can do um because it's
a scheme under an obligation so it's not
affected by the red line
i think the point is that
you would not wish to make the scheme
hostage to some other landowner because
the scheme might not be deliverable
within network rails land
so if you included that if you include a
requirement that it should rather than
shall then you ensure that there is a
reasonable opportunity to make that so
rather than binding the hand so that we
should include provision for
foot traffic both ways
i think that's that's the wording and
i'll work on that whilst debate
continues
you you express a desire
but you do leave a degree of discretion
if
the parties don't reach common sense
thank you
surpass where you're next
yeah thank you very much matthew now
listen to everybody's comments and
particularly what the ward member has
had to say and i do wonder whether we
get a little bit in danger and i'm not
being blase getting this about bit out
of proportion
i don't believe um i know exactly where
this place is i've traveled past there
quite often
um
that the
level of foot traffic is not going to be
as big as network rail consider now i
can't prove that um but i do think we
should listen to what the ward member
has to say and i
am worried that we're getting so um
concerned about this there is no such
thing as a hundred percent security
and safety and reversing the risk
equally has there been a i was going to
use the word track record but that's not
very good set of words to use has there
been examples of
serious issues and accidents on this
it's a very straight piece of rail and i
know um trains can get a fair whack
going along there but
if they were possible for example they
have fencing and i do agree with what
philip just said if you could include
there should be provision
for mitigation in both ways there is a
commitment from network rail and i know
they are remarkably tedious to deal with
and they take forever and a day
and they need to understand they're in
public service not self-service and they
need to get on with some of these
schemes so
i actually think with the comments that
we've had there in the extra condition
there listening to the ward member
the fact there is not a a
history of real difficulty there
you could put mitigation on both sides
um there are all sorts of ways of doing
that i'm not an expert but it seems to
me
barriers even if it was a light warning
system kissing gates so you can't just
go straight across or whatever it should
be
not beyond the well realms of
possibility come to a sensible agreement
between the applicant and network rail
to actually get this resolved without
further delaying what's already been
agreed because i don't think that does
us
a great deal of credit but
it is very very frustrating that network
rail are remarkably awkward to deal with
and this happens all over the place but
i don't know there's a great deal more
we can do when it comes to the planning
process
apart from putting pressure on in other
areas and from other people in order to
make it work so
i think on balance um i do think we can
approve it with those modifications um i
think councilman mayor just said in
comments of the chief planning officer
um that we can go ahead
as i say with that condition about
mitigation for both directions as
regards time scales we could say um
it should using the words should rather
than shall
um network rail need to come up say
within three months of construction but
i don't know how you enforce that
it would make the point that we expect
that um to get both sides to negotiate
and just get on with it
but i don't know we can go running
around in circles on this
but i'm not being blase about the risk
that's not what i'm saying
thank you um councilman
uh thank you chair i i i personally have
no problem whatsoever with what belleway
are proposing i think it's fine
i just wish that um more reasonable
approaches had not been considered
elsewhere in the district where we have
a slower railway line straight sections
and we have
footpath closures and temporary closures
and temporary closures and temporary
closures and it's all down to network
rail not meeting their obligation so
whilst i'm i'm quite happy with what
beltway have proposed i don't see a
problem with it i think having a gate on
on one side and yeah even better we have
a gate on the other side that can be
secured um as part of the agreement
but my concern is that
network rail
will not agree to it and and i and
therefore it's almost like we're playing
hostage
with this developer because if network
rail's
least
favored option
was the lights
um
and that is like the minimum that they
want to do
then if there aren't any lights are they
going to say
no we're not we're not considering it um
so whilst yes i'm quite happy to support
this planning application
i am very concerned about negotiations
with network rail uh going in a timely
manner
and being reasonable um you're right
it's unreasonable to expect the
developer for this size development to
cough up vast amounts of money for a
footpath that is not going to be used
that much so i i'm happy with the
planning aspect i'm just not happy with
network rail but that's this is not a
forum for slagging off network rail can
i can i just remind everyone what we're
actually can i just remind everyone what
the recommendation actually says can you
just put it up there one more time
we're being asked that an appropriate
railway mitigation scheme is delivered
we're not today picking yeah phillip so
just picking up councillor maya's points
i i'm working with that so i'd suggest
an appropriate railway railway crossing
mitigation scheme which should seek to
safeguard users in either direction
using the crossing and its timetable for
delivery relative to the occupation of
the development
yeah
now can we can we
what you've just read out phil was
getting the mitigation scheme
in a timely manner
that's agreeing what's going to be done
or are you saying it has to be
implemented um
in a reasonable time scale
dependent on the um occupation
so just to take it slowly so
appropriate railway crossing mitigation
scheme which should seek to safeguard
users in either direction using the
crossing and timetable for its delivery
relative to the occupation of the
development now the point i suppose
you're saying after that is actually
delivery in accordance with the scheme
so that's something i'd probably add in
but um i'm kind of working that through
my head as we go so yeah i mean
the scheme to be delivered in accordance
with whatever's agreed
yeah i don't think i think i mean i'm
sorry i'm jumping in it's not my turn
i'll let others we've got a lot of
people that want to speak and i'm
mindful
i've got councillor eben next thing
cancer field then councillor caston
um thank you chair um i think for
starters it's a shame we admitted to um
consult network rail back in the um
outline application which we should have
done but there we are
um i assume someone's apologizing for
that somewhere along the way but um i
think the key really is that network
rails letter in our papers says they
wish to seek acceptable mitigation
full stop so um
we wanted it we want to improve safety i
think for sure we don't want that
crossing closed
the route round to the football club
instead of that
footpath is
mainly not on paths not on foot ways
it's under a low bridge with no path
which is probably
as dangerous if not more so than
crossing the railway line so
um i think we need to be very conscious
of that and i and personally our support
this provided it is you know a scheme
and obviously network rail put forward
their you know starter for 10 and and
you negotiate from there and
and that's where um
you know bellway put forward what they
wish to do and hopefully we'll get
sensible outcome but you know
as i said network rails say they want to
seek acceptable mitigation we want to
improve the safety and let's just get on
with it thank you
okay i don't have a proposal yet but i'm
still going oh about it
no no a sec you proposed
uh right i was going to
propose that the um
to my mind the the
paragraph the sentence we have is
acceptable i don't see the issue with
that
um the point i was trying to make
earlier is that we have to understand
this is not just network rail
there is a a regulator that
actually says the office of rail
regulation who determined the safety of
the railway system
after a few major accidents in about
1840 they've been in charge
it is their decision whether you are
allowed to cross the railway at this
point
and if we put in a single-sided gate
they'll simply close the crossing end of
problem and we don't actually have any
say in that matter it's a legal
issue within government
so my view is you know we've all
exercised our various opinions uh and um
it's time to get on with with a sentence
it's quite acceptable
um we just should not underestimate the
difficulty of getting that scheme
approved
the difficulty
in a railway system is that trains
cannot stop within the vision of the
driver unlike when you're
doing something on a road where
theoretically a car can stop before it
hits anybody an obstruction in the coast
of the railway you rely on a signaling
system therefore any uh gates and things
have to be linked to that signaling
system if they are not then the
regulator will not accept position so we
you know it's all fairly clear
we don't have any great saying that all
we can do now is move on and provide
the
the
the um
the the
sentence which allows phil to
pursue the negotiation so thank you i
think it's time we all stopped
exercising our egos and got on with it
okay counselor
caston um i was going to try and get a
proposal in but that's already been done
i've looked into
how much traffic
this sees this um crossing it's actually
a
considered very high risk but um i think
that's mainly due to sun glare but um
it's some less than 10 people a day
using it at the moment the um
a klaxon would go off 91 times
a day with the trains coming through
which um cedar close and that i don't
think that's necessary i think the um
a sensible
um scheme on this would see a gate that
would stop youngsters from running
straight through in front of their
parents stop um dogs
being walked getting on there and
that would make it a lot safer safer the
um
i think best endeavors
would be enough for me for the
neighbours to get that gate there
because i
yes it could be turned into some form of
ransom
if you if you want this development
you've got to do it but i just i think
that's
quite a skeptical
way of looking at things i think they'll
want to do what's best
for the um
the people there so the people using it
um
yeah i think if you if you have serious
issues crossing the railway you won't
cross there you'll go you'll go around
so i think for me this
this way of doing things is the right
way and i fully support it thank you
okay last speaker council master and
then we'll go to the vote yeah i i this
is very very difficult and yes network
rail are very difficult to deal with i
must say when i look i looked at their
their
figures there um i thought they must
have got the decimal plot point in the
wrong place frankly i mean 140 000 would
sound like a very reasonable price
to to actually put the gates and lights
and so forth in
um
their their their their approach to
costing is is bizarre i've seen 20 000
quid quoted by them for cutting down one
tree on our land
um
if if council feels right
and they they
they can halt the whole development well
that's probably unfortunate indeed after
all the work that's been put into
getting it
right
um
on the other hand um you know there's no
doubt that
flashing light linked to the signaling
system is incredibly more effective than
just the gate
but we just wish it was being offered at
a price that that was realistic
um compared to
to the scheme and it's just very
difficult
okay so we'll go to a vote now um so
philip do you just want to remind us
what we're voting on and then we'll ask
um let's take the formal vote please
thank chairman so uh you've seen uh the
uh amendment to the recommendation that
mr vincent
terry vincent had
on the screen i'm proposing to amend the
final bullet so that it reads
appropriate railway crossing mitigation
scheme which which should seek to
safeguard users in either direction
using the crossing and timetable for its
delivery relative to occupation of the
development scheme to be delivered as
agreed thank you
and you have the conditions and the
other obligations in the package
which i think claire should have for
your modern.gov process
thank you chair
members that vote is now in progress in
your app
counselor field
thank you
thank you members that's seven votes for
on one abstention chair that's carried
okay thank you very much okay thank you
so we're going to move on to the last
application if we just ask people to
change seats very quickly yeah there any
way the heating can be put down i'm
it's really giving me a headache
we can only do that by contacting the
section so we'll send them an email and
let them know but we can't control it
ourselves
it's centrally controlled so but we'll
see if we can sort something
it's the right hand
okay so
we're going to move on to the last
application before us today
this is application dc 20587
uh uh great british business park and
then now hand over to the case officer
vincent pearce visit over to you
thank you cheer
those of you that have got the report in
colored version
the text that accompanies this the
latest
revised report is in blue
and on my in my
report the
recommendation is on page 45
but it might be on the electronic
version slightly different but it's the
one that's headed
section 3 officer recommendation 9th of
february 2022.
this has been before
various committees on various occasions
this committee last saw the application
in may
2021
where you deferred it for some
additional information
your sister committee committee b last
saw this in october
where they were minded to refuse the
application since then there have been a
number of amendments to the scheme
so my report is presented as an update
in terms of what the scheme now consists
of
and as required by your sister committee
b i've included a risk assessment
of what are the risks to the council in
the event the planning permission is
refused as i was required to
provide so
that's just proof that the resolutions
are as i
suggested
when you last looked at it you asked for
five areas of information all that
information was provided
and did achieve in my view what you'd
asked for
but you didn't get to see it a second
time because it went to committee b
because of timetabling it was ready to
go and b was the next available
committee
again i'm just using this presentation
to highlight some of the salient points
but the report is something you must
bear heavily in
in mind
since my report was written we have
received additional comment from suffolk
county council their development
contributions team but they do require
72
300 pounds
as a contribution towards educational
travel costs
there is an issue and i will come on to
that between the
applicant
and the county insofar as
they
expect their units to be occupied by
elder older members of the
the community and they seriously
question
whether or not their scheme will
generate as much school traffic as the
county council
are suggesting so the county council
have looked at this as a scheme
comprising 69 units of two and three
bedrooms
i'm sure the applicant's agent might
want to address that but we'll come on
to that in a moment just to familiarize
ourselves great bryson to the west of
the
a14 close to watisham in fact it's
immediately adjoining worsham
airfield
the flashing white
symbol is an existing
park home
wixfield park it has nothing to do with
the current applicants so
the proposal that we're looking at is
adjacent to an existing park home site
off pound hill
at the moment the site has
a multitude of nissan hut style
buildings
that are the basis of what is called the
great brexit business park
it had been um largely empty but we
understand the owner may indeed be
letting some of those units out
i haven't been there recently so i'm not
sure the latest positions so it is
previously developed land what we might
have called brownfield land in a
in a previous
iteration of the nppf
large part of the site as i showed there
in green is open
and built upon
few constraints other than there is a
public designated public footpath that
runs around the east and southern edge
of the
site there it is in in context
there you can see some of those nissan
huts style buildings
this is the adjacent
park home that's an example of some of
their their units
the proposal
consists of 69
mobile homes when you last looked at it
there was some confusion as to whether
it might be 73 or 69 it is definitely
69 and what has happened
in the interim we have additional
planting along this boundary and along
the frontage
to help soften the impact of what are
single story
units and there is an area of open space
included
in here
the previous scheme the outline planning
permission for 51
dwellings
is extant and we received reserved
matters
at the end of december
2021 before it expired in january so
there is
a live
reserved matters application the
importance of that is
that with the outline planning
permission for 51 units there is a
section 106 agreement that would deliver
35 affordable housing within
a traditional
housing scheme that has outlined
planning permission we haven't
determined the reserve matters yet
that's something that we're currently
looking at
if i put one across the other here's the
latest uh park home layout
we just superimpose over the top
the outline illustrative drawing for 51
and
you can see that perhaps the
arrangement of dwellings is looser
but those properties do fill most of the
site and go up to the site boundaries
they also use the existing business park
access road as would the park home site
this is the
this is the access to
wicksfield park the adjacent
caravan park
this scheme and the 51 housing scheme
includes new footpath connection
from
the great brassica business park to this
existing section of footway that takes
you
up towards watershed airfield
just to illustrate that the dashed
yellow line is the existing path you can
see wixfield caravan park at the top
this is the application site sitting in
here
the applicants are proposing a new bus
stop
and
a reasonable length of footway to
connect
the existing path to this site
the bus stop and the path are also
included in the 51 house
proposal
you asked us before when you looked at
this in may to assure you that there was
reasonable public transport to and from
the site
in our view there is compared to a lot
of um rural communities great price it
is
reasonably
served
that's an indication of the mix of units
they're two and three bed of different
sizes why i can't give you a plan
showing layout is these are
depending on what the purchaser requires
they can be adapted and are relatively
bespoke in terms of how the internals
are laid out
as you can see that does produce 69
units
you had concerns about how would parking
work
and each of those plots is capable of
accommodating
two vehicles
and there is scope for visitor parking
within the site so we are satisfied that
the park home scheme would not result in
congestion on the adjacent roads there's
adequate room for parking
in terms of landscaping this is
something that we did go back and we
have secured amendments
so
for example
on the eastern corner
in here
we've got extended
planting that will buffer this
development from countryside
countryside views remember there's a
public footpath that runs
around the perimeter
on the frontage
rather than having exposed frontage to
the side that will now be enclosed with
a landscaping belt and again
on the southern boundary there's
the beginnings of an avenue and
additional planting on the edge
this is examples of the type of unit
that would be provided on this this site
in and of themselves
we have no no issues about the design of
of those
so since the 29th of october
the applicant has increased
their offer
as a contribution towards affordable
housing offsite from 168 000
to 200 000
and you may remember this scheme was not
delivering
affordable housing in the sense that you
and i understand affordable housing in
terms of affordable rented
or
affordable
shared ownership
i'll come on to
the
position on how they see their
development but they're not providing
affordable rented or shared ownership
they did offer to make a contribution
towards that offsite that the council
could use to deliver
affordable homes of the type it
requires they have extended the offer
when we looked at this last time you
didn't see it in may but by october
the applicants had agreed to provide an
off on-site shop
it's something that came out of
discussion previously
i think some members felt wouldn't it be
nice for the village to have access to a
local small convenience
store the applicants have offered to
provide that
they have now increased that offer to
five years to run it within the site
available to everyone in the village at
the end of that period they would offer
it to the community on a rent-free basis
and the community could almost run it as
a social
enterprise
we do have electric vehicle charging
commitments
effectively 100
across the 69
units and each will now
previously it was going to be
served by gas
each of the park homes would have air
source heat pumps
uh the applicant is satisfied that they
have can get enough electricity on the
site to run all of that
there would be options as well for pv
panels
at individuals request as an extra so
they can either have them on the roof or
free standing
as i say we have now received the
reserve matters for the 51
dwellings so if we look at a
comparison only because um
i'll come on to why but
in terms of the
amended scheme we've got
certain elements are similar so both
schemes the outline planning permission
for 51 and this scheme
both provide new footway connections
both provide the new bus shelter both
include additional landscaping
what the park home scheme
includes as we say we know that they are
willing to provide air source heat pumps
hundred percent they are willing to
provide fully eb charging and they will
provide the shop for five years
moment the 51 dwellings
were not
able to report on how much of that would
be delivered they are certainly not
including a new shop
if i quickly move on to the risks
associated with a refusal which was
your sister committee b
as intention as we say they're reminded
to refuse
and the basis of their objection was
that they felt
that the
then
168 000 was a poor substitute for
17.8 affordable homes that would be
delivered through the
outline planning commission
and they felt that the failure to
deliver on-site
affordable homes
was a significant and serious
deviation from your adopted policy h4 in
terms of the requirement for affordable
homes
the park home scheme is also opposed by
your strategic housing team who believe
it doesn't provide the sort of housing
that is needed within the district in
terms of affordable housing
if we work out the the difference in
terms of what would 200 000 potentially
buy in terms of the council then using
that to deliver off-site affordable
housing
there will be a differential of 15 units
compared to what we might secure on site
through the 51 house scheme
the issue for members is if you believe
that the position on affordable housing
is
decisive or in a determinative
factor
you would be recommending
refusal in line with your sister
committee
back in october
so let's briefly look at
some of the maths
a park home
uh unit
two bed might sell
at circa 150 000 you don't rent them
you don't lease them you buy that unit a
three bed might cost 170 000
and what the applicant argues is
that they are offering affordable
equivalents
to brick built
two and three bed units
in the area and i think it's probably
true to say that
the prices here
are less than you might expect to pay
for a brick-built
alternative and in the minds of the
applicants that makes them affordable
now in response the council is going to
say at the moment we have in excess of
600 applicants on the housing register
three of those have a local connection
to great brice it those people are not
in a position to buy
accommodation
we are looking for affordable rented
accommodation or shared ownership so
that somebody can staircase a very low
level of equity and move up the ladder
so in our terms and in the terms that
are colleagues in strategic housing
except these are not affordable
what we might say is these are low-cost
or
low-cost units
but what
what the applicant is not offering to do
is to offer 35 of these units at a
market value below the rest of the
development so these are you can't buy
35 percent on the site that 20 cheaper
than the remainder they're all the same
price for the same size bedroom unit so
we think even on that score they can't
reasonably argue that somehow this is a
discount
proposal
you and i know that the council is
looking to deliver 127 affordable houses
as we understand them per year for the
foreseeable future
the loss of
effectively 15
dwellings
is significant that means that there are
potentially 15
households on the register who will not
be able to get the sort of accommodation
that we require
and again with the 51 house scheme we've
got a we've secured the mix so there
will be 70
rented
30 shared equity of those 17 units
so the question that might come to mind
is how come we as officers have changed
our minds because twice before we've
provided reports where we're supporting
the proposal this time
we are now recommending refusal
but the answer
because i wrote the report is we're not
just saying refuse because that's what
your sister
committee
suggested should happen in october
in our minds there has been some
significant changes to circumstance
since october
so the first one of those is that we
know that the jlp process has gone down
a different path
site allocations
are not as clear as they
they might have been
we have had despite protestations to the
country we have received a reserved
matters application
so we now think that there is a viable
opportunity of securing those
17.8 affordable homes
and we do know
recently published that we have a 9.5
year
housing land supply
we know that the previous outline
planning permission was granted at a
time when we did not
have a five-year
housing land supply
what are the prospects of delivery
of the 51 house scheme you'll notice
from the report that we quote in detail
the land owner suggesting that he will
not be
selling the site for
a traditional residential scheme
so in terms of the screen what i'm
suggesting is the landowner has told us
he will not sell the land for the 51
house scheme
but we do have reserve matters in for a
51 house proposal
the basis for the landowner suggesting
he will not sell is
the
park home scheme
the offer made on the land is higher
than an offer suggested for the
residential scheme
so i suppose you might say why would he
want why would he sell the land for a 51
house scheme if he can get a higher
value
from the park home scheme
the bottom line according to the
landowner and the information that's
been submitted to us in terms of
viability is that worthy mobile home
scheme to fail
either you refuse it or it's lost at
appeal
he would then
relaunch the business park because that
would provide a greater return
than selling the land
for the 51 house development
i'm no expert i don't know what will
happen the landowner may could have a
change of heart and all sorts of things
could happen in the future but at the
moment the landowner is stating he will
not sell the land for the 51 house
scheme
that does raise a question what happens
if the 51 house scheme does not
proceed
and we no longer have a land allocation
a site allocation for residential
development and the residential
development lapses
that's just in the background you're
here just to look at the merits of the
park home scheme
but it is relevant in in the number of
ways i've just talked through the
possibilities what i'm not suggesting is
that members you look at
is the park home scheme preferable or
not to the 51 house scheme if you have
to judge this scheme on its merits but
it is a material consideration
that the park home scheme does not
deliver your policy requirement on
affordable homes but the outline
permission
does
and that in our minds offices has has
reinforced
the feeling of your sister committee
that actually
the failure to deliver 35
affordable homes on this site within the
park home scheme is seriously um
contrary to
policy and is a material consideration
that suggests it should be refused on
the grounds that it fails to meet your
affordable housing
policy
i'll just leave the slide on the screen
as a reminder of the
that's the end of the presentation okay
thank you very much for that very
comprehensive coverage um you've got a
few hands that go up council field then
council matheson
yes just a couple questions one on the
uh normal process with affordable homes
were this just any development
we would expect 35
of the
69 homes to be affordable
i.e
they are sold at a discount to a housing
provider for rent
and that discount is 20
is that correct
i might have confused things
what would happen is we would normally
expect 35 of the total to be affordable
yeah a split of generally 70 to 30
70
of that 35 rented
30 of that 35
shared ownership
what i was alluding to in terms of the
20 there's a new a different product
called discount on
low-cost housing
whereby a developer can offer to sell
that property at 20 30
below the value of the rest of the
properties
and what happens is that obviously helps
certain buyers to get into the housing
market but my understanding is that when
it comes to sell that property
you still have to then sell it as a 20
or 30
discount but you are required to buy it
and that's the difference we would
expect rented because people on the
housing register cannot afford to buy
yeah i was just trying to see the
financial impact on the provider of
providing 35 percent affordable homes
because
you okay you've put that in three
different segments
i still don't know how much he sells the
affordable homes to the housing provider
for i believe that two is a 20 discount
but i was asking you to confirm that
before i let you go on can i just point
out i'm looking at page
593
ra 5.13
it says the figure of 168 000 is derived
from twenty percent of the construction
cost of a park home
times seventeen
brackets i.e 35 percent of the total
number of units
i.e
7 000 pounds
which is presumably 20 percent of the
cost of a park home times 24
which i think is different from 17
equals 168 000.
could you explain where the errors in
that calculation or my understanding are
fat calculation is one that is not
supported by our strategic housing
colleagues
they they have worked out that an
equivalent payment i didn't ask that i
asked where the error in that so that is
what is it
an error i'm going to explain however
that figure comes about but
in order to
explain how we got to that figure which
is a compromise figure i need to explain
that our strategic housing team
have indicated that the
equivalent payment
for 35 percent would be seven over seven
hundred thousand what this calculation
is is a compromise figure that seeks to
take the construction cost of a
of a mobile home
and then apply
a 20 discount on the basis that the
applicant is saying that these are lower
cost housing they're not affordable
which would
produce the 20 discount that gives you
the 7 000
figure multiplied by the 35
ends up at 168.
but that is a purely um
[Music]
artificial calculation and it isn't one
that our
strategic housing colleagues
their view is that a more accurate
comparison would be 700 000 but the
applicant has indicated they will not
and cannot afford a 700 000 payment to
get a much better equivalent of
delivering affordable housing of a type
that we
require i think that's the point you've
got to earlier
the delivery of affordable housing of a
type that we require
is expensive for a developer and it's
more than 20
at the moment we're working on the basis
of a build cost of 76 000 pounds for a
two-bed
unit
and i think you pointed out that many
councils do accept mobile homes as
affordable units but ours does not is
that right
i haven't pointed that out i'm not
trying to pick hairs but the applicant
has produced some evidence that others
do we don't
i mean there is ground between us and
i'm sure the um agent will want to refer
to that okay councilor matherson
thank you when uh right at the beginning
on slide three i did i did
note to ask
um
that the existing use of the sites half
of it's got these these this and huts on
it and which
we'll assume are um
generally rented out um it's the whole
site
that's to say the other half of it
that's all got grass on it at the moment
is that has that also got employment
existing use
on it which
in fact you came that the question then
reoccurred right at the end effectively
in your presentation when when um that
was the preferred option of the
of the applicant to to
expand and develop a lot i just wonder
whether that's actually
effectively already before us as
you know or permission effectively
the site i would argue enjoys lawful use
rights for
business use
so if the owner wanted to reopen and
relaunch the business using the existing
buildings
that is perfectly within his rights and
he wouldn't have to come back to you as
the planning authority if you wanted to
demolish those and replace them that
would need planning permission if you
wanted to extend onto the green field
that would also need planning permission
but technically it's part of the same
site and has lawful use rights for
for business use
okay uh councilman
thank you um i i think i've got
two questions but i might have forgotten
the other one now um
can you tell me if park homes would
count in our housing delivery numbers
and if they don't um
what effect that has if we grant this
does that affect our
housing numbers
and the other question was does the
whatever decision we make today
have any effect on future determination
of the 51
houses reserve matters um should that
be um
continuing whatever based on whatever we
decide today
we do not include park homes in our
housing calculations
we have
adequate land as we said was it the 9.7
yes supply without
the inclusion of any park homes
so
were this site
not to come forward it wouldn't have any
impact on your
housing numbers
the
second point is the reserved matters
will be judged on their own
merits it has the benefit of outline
planning permission if it if it's of a
quality that
is
to your liking then
you want to reasonably assume it might
get plenty permission however
if it had faults and issues we might not
approve the reserved matters but the
principle has been established
okay thank you yeah you want to come
back
the does the
rese the outline permission for 51
is that included in our nine point
whatever year's
land supply as part of the numbers so so
okay we've got plenty but if we lose 51
here we have to find 51 for somewhere
else it was included um
based on evidence provided by the owner
our colleagues in the policy team
did not include it
um but the differential of that 51 will
not make a serious impact on your
housing land
supply we would not be asking another
community to find 51
as recompense
thank you
okay so we're going to move on to the
public speakers then
okay so um first of all we have from the
parish council brings your paris council
we have david payne
uh um
with respect chairman
i
i unders i came along here expecting a
gentleman on my right to speak on behalf
of rachel parish council
and i was informed that they were
a statutory um
um
what's it called um
so you are here to speak as an
now he is now speaking as an objector
yes so in the pecking order he should go
before me
uh yes correct the parish council goes
first the paris council goes first and
an ordinary objector can come along
after me yes
i'm really sorry but i call it in the
order and it's the same order for every
meeting so we go public speakers parish
council objective supporter agent
uh counsellor right okay every meeting
is the same so the first person to speak
is the parish council right so and you
have three minutes thank you for
clearing that out
um
my parish council
uh it'd be quite frank it doesn't want
either the 51 houses or the 69 mobile
homes
that i've explained to them that that is
a
a ridiculous situation to try and
go forward on because
the outline planning consent for 51
homes has already been given so you
can't argue against that and it's the
letter of two evils
we either
support the 51 houses
or
we've and
side by side with that we actually um
vote against and object most strongly to
the mobile homes because
if you saw that map we already have 70
probably 75 on wicksfield park and still
growing up to 80
at a stroke this committee if it gives
consent for those
uh the adjoining land uh great bright
state park we will suddenly have 150
plus mobile homes which will
which will make our
our community
somewhat lopsided
and skewed
and so we
definitely if we want more housing we
want brick-built houses rather than
temporary homes that are bolted together
and
and having said that even the even the
gentleman
appearing on behalf of the
uh the um
the park home developer he could see
that the lifespan is 71 years well how
can that be a sustainable housing it
will have to be carted away after 20
70 years and another one comes along
you've got to have dwellings there which
last
p there's some
facts cottages in areas go back 500
years and they're still there all right
we want
we want sustainable houses with footings
called dwellings not things bolted
together
um as regards the figures showing a high
preponderance of
men in our village that's skewed by the
fact that we've got um
watches of watching airfield and watch
him is is a misleading title for this
airfield because most of the well all of
the homes are neither in what hashem
they're in great bright sit and ringshaw
and
so
that skews and
of of the on the airfield there are
probably something in the region of
about
probably a thousand
probably 500 at least
soldiers there who live within the
um the parameter of the the the guarded
section they never come out and and take
part in the in the community
life event in fact when you i met some
of them on uh
remembrance day and they often go off
for three months some chaps goes to
canada for six months of the year
um so
to bring
so these figures showing that um
it we we're worried that we'll have a
sort of one foot in the grave
development right in the center of our
village i will have to ask for the last
sentence now because the time's up well
the
the best we were told that the the thing
that we were voting for just let me just
get this was to the best possible
uh
decision and the best possible decision
is to divide
five acres among five well i will have
to call this today okay thank you
remember 51. i'm sorry i'm sorry
the time is up and you can only we only
can give you three minutes i'm afraid so
thank you for that um do we have any
questions at all for the parish council
yeah council field
could you tell me how many homes there
are in great brisette you make the point
about 140 being a substantial percentage
how many are there in total
answer that categorically because
um incidentally i
i am an occupant of a shared equity
house in great prices so i have an
interest in that sense
um
i don't know the answer to that
i um i presume the figures are in here
but um
i i'll have i'd have to come back on
that sorry no problem okay
no it's okay sorry
we can just answer the question thank
you and any other questions at all for
the parish council
no okay well thank you very much for
that i now hand over to an objector uh
mr christopher payne again three minutes
please
uh thank you chair and the planning
officer for uh planning offices for
their reports and the council's their
due diligence in considering this
application i did attend the previous um
meeting as well i am chairman of
ringshaw parish council presumably i can
say that as but i'm objecting
on my own account
um i also acknowledge the agent's work
on behalf of the applicant as well
um
what i want to say was that um
the proposed extensive development is
unsustainable in this locate location
and out of scale with the surrounding
area
which already has a large but
proportionate mobile home
site the wixel park site
selective highlighting by the
applicant's representatives in the
reports about the integrity of the
surrounding area
sorry about the
about various planet planning appeals
and its submissions to mid-south
district council
um about other far-off locations has no
commonality with the ham is a hamlet of
great the great british we heard from
council casten last time that um there's
a high call out for ambulances in
um in these sites so we're concerned
also about the
strain on existing medical services
doctors services and so forth the
resubmission
does little to maintain the integrity of
the surrounding area and still does not
represent an affordable low-cost form of
housing compatible
with affordable affordable housing has
claimed and it fails to address the
issues of local homes for young people
and i want to stand in
i want my children to have the option of
buying affordable homes in the future
which they can't do at the moment in
your the the officers report on page 8
four it says bryce is defined as a
countryside village countryside in the
adopted core strategy
and it says that the second significance
uh it is a location where the
development plan explicitly directs that
development should generally not take
place and it says in the next paragraph
the significance being that the growth
is notting the growth is not encouraged
i think um
uh improving this planning application
will deliver a dramatic increase in the
number of mobile homes in great price
it would represent a significant and
overwhelming top-heavy disproportionate
increase in this type of home compared
with the existing
conventional properties in great prices
and i go along with the report that i
would opt for getting more affordable
homes than the two that we're being
offered uh with this that with this
development thank you
thank you very much
do we have any questions for the
objector
no
okay thank you very much for that
um okay we don't have a supporter here
but we do have the agent or the
applicant i've got two names down here
my apologies i've got uh richard budder
and nick glaser but
over to you yes uh richard buther from
rps representing the applicant flying
solo today
thank you chair as the case officer has
rightly pointed out in his report
the site
the subject of this application does
have the benefit of an extent outline
planning permission for residential
development
the broader principle of residential
development on the site in relation to
access
access to local services facilities
sustainability
impact on the local highway network and
parking drainage and loss of employment
land has therefore been established
this proposal for mobile homes has come
forward because the original proposal
has not proved to be viable from the
landowner's point of view
critically
we say that the proposal does
compromise affordable housing and we
draw on the mppf definition of
affordable housing and several recent
clear appeal decisions to support our
position on this matter
as mr price has also said this
application has previously been before
both planning committees and on each
occasion we have listened very carefully
to the debate and amended the proposals
or provided additional information where
required
in particular we've improved the
landscaping along the southern boundary
of the site
we've provided notwithstanding
falling the definition of affordable
housing a commuted sun for off-site
provision of affordable housing
we've provided an on-site shop available
for residents of the park and the wider
community
we've ensured the park homes will meet
or exceed british standards for energy
efficiency
we'll fit each unit with 100 amp
electricity supply and air-to-water heat
pumps
we'll fit all visitor spaces with ev
charging points
and have the option for ev charging
points for each of the units
we've provided further information on
local bus services the need for the
accommodation provided and how the
purchase of homes can be financed
how the site will be lit
how foul drainage will be dealt with on
site
and most recently we've responded
receptively to the very late request for
a contribution towards secondary school
transport
the 69 units can be counted towards the
council's housing land supply
the ministry of housing local government
and communities guidance note from
september 2020 makes clear as does a
number of high court cases and planning
appeal decisions that this is the case
the units will provide affordable
single-story homes that are aimed at
older people but which are underprovided
in the area and will complement the
adjacent park home site
as a final point i'd like to emphasize
that this development will be brought
forward by birch's group
which is family-run business
rps act for a number of large park home
developers
and it is our opinion that birches are
the most considerate and high quality
operator
it has an exceptional reputation for
developing and operating sites and
developing sites with long-term vision
and i trust the committee will
reconsider his previous decisions and
approve this application
thank you chair thank you very much for
that do we have any questions at all for
the agent
yes councilman i think it's more a
question for the officer but it's been
triggered by what the agent just said um
the agent said that the 69 homes do
count towards housing land supply and
that is at complete odds with what we
heard from the officer um previously so
could we have that confirmed one way or
the other
despite the fact it may be an
insignificant number but i'd still like
to know which is correct i can confirm
that
robert hubbs our
planning policy manager has confirmed
that we do not include them
i think the point being made by mr
buther is that some authorities do
but categorically we do not
thank you for that any other questions
for the applicant no okay so i'm not
going to move on uh thank you for that
we now move on to the ward member
council daniel pratt and i'll read out
uh he can't be here today so he's asked
me to read this out
as the ward member for great brices i'm
writing to affirm my position
in that i remain opposed to the planning
application to cite 69 homes on the
business park the resubmission of this
application fails to address concerns
it has not resolved the problems of
scale posed by the number of dwellings
only four less units compared to the
original application
with 69 dwellings the site is
overcrowded creating an environment that
undermines the well-being of future
inhabitants
the number of dwellings is also highly
unsustainable for a settlement of hamlet
classification
the number of dwellings is far higher
than the range needed to accommodate
natural growth and local need
i previously highlighted at length
reasons for objecting based on
sustainability
such as enhanced pressure on poor
infrastructure drainage concerns lack of
a shop and facilities and
over-subscribed health services
the applicant had cited examples of
precedent cases that support their
application but failed to highlight how
the nature and situation of sites in
these cases are appropriate or bear any
semblance of the context and situation
of this proposal
it was noted in the planning b committee
meeting held on the october the 29th
councillors had resolved to reject the
application on the basis that the mobile
homes have a short lifespan of a maximum
70 years were practical practically
unmortgageable and would not benefit
people in the under 40 age group which
includes most families
in this way the proposal fails to
provide a viable affordable housing
solution that meet local need
simultaneously the applicant has
submitted planning application dc 21
06987
for 51 dwellings that originally granted
permission in 2019
but due to expire
this proposal would provide conventional
permanent homes with 35 affordable
housing accessible to younger citizens
and families
it also provides a larger proportion of
green and open space compared to the
application for 69 mobile homes
i take the view that if we are to have
development on this scale and great
bracelet at all
it would be in the best public interest
to refuse the current proposal for
mobile homes
and the view that we gain eighteen
affordable homes
that are both permanent and mortgageable
from the recently resubmitted proposal
for the site
thank you for the consideration dr
daniel pratt board member for rick
control battered
okay
so that's it folks we've had everything
put before us all the information is up
to us to
discuss and come to conclusion that
council even straight up
um thank you thank you chair and firstly
i just want to say that i think it's a
shame that this has been such a drawn
out application and that all the people
are putting work into it whether it's
the applicant
residents parish councils planning
offices and so on to be a committee
three different occasions is
it's just unfortunate and i think
we should acknowledge the work that goes
into these tough applications
um however um i'm of the view that the
i think this is inappropriate here i
think we need
you know if great bryce is going to have
any housing it does need some affordable
homes um and
some
housing that meets the needs of the
local um population
and i'm sure they these people do good
developments but will they'll they will
if this went ahead they would have a
kind of 150 odd park homes all
um becoming you know available for
for one sort of section of the
population as it were and it would would
not be appropriate
in such a small village
so chair i'd be happy to
propose
this refusal in line with the officer
recommendations and
but happy to hear others on the
committee thank you thank you very much
yeah councillor madison
yes i i
i mean i i think the the policy argument
is is is strong um what what clinches it
for me really is is the
undesirability of having a a settlement
of 150 park homes
out there in in the countryside in
hamlet i think
we were told so i i've got no hesitation
in actually seconding that
and i think we can view with with
equanimity let's say
that we might
um we might get a continuing and
expanded business
on this site
or we might
get the houses and the affordables and
either way
um
would be better than um
than approving this one thank you
cancer field and cancer possible
[Music]
similar question comments really i do
feel that um
140 affordable homes really does skew
the local accommodation to a
a particular form uh very and what we
really want is mixed uh mixed
villages with
a range of individuals a range of
different sized houses matching their
economic positions and needs so i
i find that a a problem
i do feel the
probability of the 50 houses being
delivered seems to be rather low but
nevertheless it's um it will be a more
attractive position to local people as
the
war mirrors explained so i'm inclined to
go along with the rejection thank you
casa passman yep thanks matthew um i'm
not going to repeat what everybody else
has said but and i know we have to look
at each application on its own merits
and that's really really important
and i i'm not in favor of this one i
can't see any reason to
go against the recommendation the
officers in this case as i say i'm
looking at it entirely on its own merits
and we don't have an application for
normal construction brick-built houses
and so on we prefer that but actually i
think for the reason stated here and for
the fact that um if we were to give this
one i think there would be a degree of
inconsistency without sufficient
mitigation to justify
so that's my opinion
thank you and just to add to my bit i
think the officers presented a very
clear application before us and the
reasons laid out to me i agree
wholeheartedly with and so
without going through it all again i'll
support the officer's recommendation as
well
okay so i think no one else wishes to
speak so i think we're going to go to a
vote so can you just remind us what
we're being asked to decide please
[Music]
so chairman the recommendation
is on page 605 of your agenda that the
application be refused and there's a
full length reason for refusal there
if you also refer to your table papers
on the
third page of that page nine
third item on that there is an
additional request for a revised uh
recommendation to refuse permission on
an additional ground that includes
reference to the failure to adequately
mitigate
uh impact of development in respect of
demand on educational services and the
context is set out there so effectively
you have a long hand reason for refusal
on page 605
and on page nine you have a summary
which officers will work up as a reason
for refusal has full text
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress council of field
thank you
thank you members chair that is seven
votes
sorry eight votes for refusal that's
carried okay thank you very much that's
unanimous okay so uh final item on the
agenda is site inspections do we have
any site inspections requests that need
to be recorded to the committee
okay
i realize that i i admitted to say this
time on the on the bachelor application
that i went on the site visit with the
other committee back in the day of 2019
or 18 or something should have said that
again sorry i forgot
i think if you're if you're on the
you're in another committee at a
different time that's that's fine okay
okay everyone well thank you very much
for joining us today um we closed the
meeting and you'll notice now both
clocks say the same time which is is is
a breakthrough at 15 14.
thanks everyone